I am one content creator, you [__] I don't care about
your fight with Destiny online. I'm just not supporting JD Vans.
No, I never said support JD Vance. You baboon. [laughter]
And these are like, "No, you have to vote for the guy who was
uh anti-billionaires tax and you have to like it." It's like,
"Shut the [__] up." No, I'm not going to do that.
Shut the up. Shut the up. Shut your stupid liberal mouth. Okay.
just for people who are rolling in, here's the clip we're talking
about. I'll let this play real quick. Okay. I'm disappointed
in >> vote for JD Vance or Gavin Newsome. >> Well,
I'd have to vote for Gavin Newsome, course. >> I wouldn't
blink. What about you, >> I'd probably vote third party.
>> You would?
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, I at that point it doesn't even matter.
Like, cuz my policy on this is is the same as like my refusal
to endorse Kla Harris. Um, the reason why I did not endorse Kla
Harris was because she did things that were not only unproductive
but also unconscionable.
Um, but and I still stand on that. I still talk about it all
the time cuz people constantly bring it up. They're like, you
didn't sufficiently like promote Kla Harris. You're the reason
why she lost. I'm like, I am incapable.
There is no singular force in this country that is capable of
making or breaking an election. And if that was real,
then it is the most idiotic thing not to listen to my demands.
But everybody knows that that's not real, right? If I had this
singular force to be able to make Kla Harris the president, then
Kla Harris should be coming to me every day and being like, "Let
me do a collab with you, please." Totally. Right. That's not
the case, of course, and they know it. That's why they didn't
do it. But
um the the campaigns are always responsible for whether or not
they are able to win uh the crowds, win the population over and
and you know combat against the couch, not necessarily even against
the Republican party, but usually you're fighting against the
couch, people who just don't go out and vote.
And for me, the way I see it is if the Democratic establishment
makes this decision one more time, just as they did with Hillary
Clinton, just as they did with Kla
>> and in some ways, just as they did with Joe Biden as
well, which led to Trump,
>> then they just don't care. And there's not much. >> Let
me tell you something. >> Okay. Anyway, we're done with
this. I want to go to what is there? We're apparently going to
get a time stamp and then I think there's a little bit more here
as well. We had one more post that Hassad was reacted to, I think.
Let's see here.
Insanely irresponsible take given the harm this administration
has unleashed in just just one year in. Okay.
Supporting Gavin Newsome is supporting
I understand again. So, the way I see this is is Mike and the
people around Mike and Hassan are basically trying to negotiate.
Yeah, that's the way I see it. It's like they have to say these
things. I don't necessarily I don't necessarily think that even
Mike, okay, I think Mike is way more of a
like commie if you're going to use that word. He's way more communist
than Hassan is, right? Like he's the guy who I
his channel's called Central Committee. Okay, his His channel's
literally called Central Committee. And I don't even think he
truly believes that like, oh, I would vote for, you know, third
party if JD Vance was against Gavin Newsome. I really don't believe
that. They'll say it, [clears throat] but
it is what it is.
Anyway, Hassan responded to this person. Bend the knee to the
left or sorry, bend the knee to the left then. You already did
with Zoron. The midterms just started and y'all are crying about
the general. Do you want free healthcare? Do you want free college?
Do you want to stop Israel? I'll vote for anyone who sincerely
believes in making that happen. You can't see the difference
between JD Vance and Gavin Newsome and the difference in the
people hurt by one versus the other. then I can't help you.
>> Okay, I do notice,
man.
Again, there's like another thing here. All my thoughts were
well collected last night and then I got no sleep and they're
they're disperate now. They're all It's like I had the picture
put together and it's shattered. But don't worry, I'll figure
it out. Like, if you just break it down to issues, it's like,
okay, what issues do you disagree with Hassan on? Stop making
it about like uh what do you call it? Like socialists versus
liberals. just talk about the issues like where are you guys
actually
I I never see I'm sure you guys do have differences but I never
see the differences play out on Twitter. It's just like you commies
you libs.
I don't know. Hassan says basically here are my issues and if
you are willing to you know support my issues then I'll vote
for you and I'll I'll support voting for you. If you can't see
the difference between JD Vance and Gavin Newsome the difference
between or in people hurt by one versus the other then I can't
help you. I don't know if he said that, but we go to the next
tweet
or is this No, this is the tweet I just pulled up. H, hold on.
Then she quote tweets him. Go close these. If you can't see the
difference between JD Vance and Gavin Newsome and the difference
in the people hurt by one versus the other. Oh, it's the same.
It's the same message. Let's go.
Let's go. Let's go.
Okay. She took her reply and she made it a quote tweet.
And so we see the Hassan quote tweet back. I never said JD Vance
is better than Newsome. You don't believe I said that because
you can't comprehend a world where democracy implies asking for
concessions from your elected representatives before doing loyalty
pledges to them like a happy surf.
Uh yeah, I do I do think that seems to be what he's trying to
do. He says probably vote third party is and he's like I don't
like Gavin Newsome. What I hear there is I I hate Gavin Newsome.
I hate the idea of Gavin Newsome leading my party. I hate it.
Right. And thereafter he says, "I I don't like doing the loyalty
pledge thing. I don't like doing that, especially not this far
out from the
It seems It just seems pretty obvious. Anyway,
never said you think Vance is better. Stop trying to wiggle out
of
Wait, what? Okay, that they're equal. I would say equal is something
Hassan said. I see what he's doing. I see he's you can't see
the difference between JD Vance and Gavin Newsome. Okay. She's
arguing that JD Vance is worse. And Hassan's like, "Well,
that may be true.
I don't know why he said this. This is
this is not what she said." That's a valid point. Never said
you think Vance is better. Stop trying to wiggle out of this.
You were given the scenario of Vance or Newsome. You said third
party. And you're rightfully being called out for that, which
the host also says to your own face. Just own what you said.
Oh, nobody. By the way, the host literally agrees with Hassan
after this. When Hassan lays out his rationale, the host literally
agrees with Hassan. Now, I don't know if that's because the host
is like a friend of Hassan's and like believes in Hassan's politics
and is just like going on with him or whatever,
but I do think it's funny that nobody watched the full clip.
Anyway, I'm not trying to wiggle out of anything. Vance versus
Newsome might give Vance the edge, but even a marginal victory
over JD,
Vance versus Newsome might give Vance the edge, but even a marginal
victory over JD with establishment politics will continue to
usher in American fascism. We need to fight fascist politics,
not concede to them, and ratchet the nation right. I'm all for
pushing Dems to be better, but when the decision is ice gestapo
raids continue versus no raids with a bad Dem, I think we have
a moral obligation to take whatever path available out of the
madness and protect our marginalized communities that are impacted
by this admin. I'm a daughter of Arab immigrants, so I take this
seriously. Third party will always be a no for me. We we have
some time till 2028, so of course we can spend that time advocating
for the best candidate to get us there.
Yeah, that's what he's doing. I I assume that's what he's doing.
Uh anyway,
I both of these arguments are fine. I don't see somebody is like
totally wrong here. They're just they're talking about they're
doing different things.
Did I get that time stamp? Hold on. Let me see here. I did get
that time stamp.
I hope everyone's having a fantastic evening, afternoon, preune,
no matter where we are in the world. No matter where you are
in the world. I'm Son [__] and this is Dustin Broadcast
coming to you live from not so sunny but mostly cloudy Los Angeles,
California on stolen land. Tongva stolen land. We're live. We're
live and I hope all the boys, girls, and embies are having a
fantastic one because today is a beautiful day. Today is a wonderful
day. Today is
Wednesday or No, sorry. Yeah, it is Wednesday. Wednesday. It's
Wednesday. It is. Hey,
I'm not the only one who makes that decision. Let's go.
Or decision. I'm not the only one who makes that mistake. My
brain is not going to work, bro. I'm I have not slept enough.
I can tell already. >> Hey, Wednesday fe. >> That
was me. That was me. I did that today. I literally was like,
it's Thursday, right? Wednesday, Thursday. A viable opposition
party who also simultaneously understand
the squirrel decided that today's a good day to jump on the dog
pile against you. Yes, because they're mentally ill. Okay, they're
mentally ill. Those leftists are mentally ill and I'm sick and
tired of
And you know, if you're a liberal and you're watching this, just
take some
small satisfaction for yourself, okay? That Hassan
himself faces the same issue with the Dem like that he he he
poses this problem to the Democratic party where he's outsider
who's like putting pressure on the thing that he doesn't quite
belong to, that isn't quite extreme enough for him, right? and
that the Z squirrel, um, bad empanada, those people are are like
he's the den party and they're Hassan [__] okay?
He has his own microcosm of this exact issue going on where he
is consistently being pressured by those people who cannot seemingly
be, you know, satisfied with anything he says or does, he's got
the same thing. So, just know that whatever hell he's putting
you through, he's also being put through himself. Okay. >> Every
single time.
>> Yes. Those are the people I'm talking about. Anyway,
we're going to talk about Bondi and you're clearly trying to
be effective. I don't know why they do this. I know why they
do this. Because they are in a cult. At least the Pestin fans
are in a
>> quite literally is in a cult. And uh the only thing
that they care about is like coming after me and being like we
need to remove Assan from the throws of the Democratic party.
It's like you're not it's not going to work. Okay. It's not you're
a idiot. like you're you're literally just consistently advocating
>> and he complains about those people regularly. You know
why he complains? Because it's effective cuz those people keep
him from moving rightward and it's painful cuz he he would like
to he'd like to just have a you know Hassan in his heart he yearns
for some like fist bumps with Gavin Newsome but bad and Padaata
and those people they just keep pulling him further left. Okay,
it's like effective. This strategy is always effective. That
is why it's so annoying for people because then Hassan has to
deal with questions from those from those leftist viewers of
like, hey, why are you like not doing this? Why are you not doing
that? Right? It's the same
>> Ruining the Democratic party. Um that's what you're
doing.
And it's very frustrating. Like I want to stop the bleeding.
I want to stop the pain. Um I don't care about whatever squirrel
is saying. It does not matter. Uh their position is utterly irrelevant
in this conversation. They're not here. They're not in America.
Who gives a You don't have to ri up the libs if you'd vote for
a Newsome and just have and just want concessions. Just say that
again. No, I don't care. I don't care. I don't I don't think
there's any utility in
uh lying about this [__] I'm not going to concede
to voting for I'm not going to concede to voting for Gavin Newsome
two years out of the two years out of the gate. Like, it's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous. Okay, get the hell out of here. Find a better
candidate. Suck my
Gavin Newsome is currently
pushing against Roana
in the in the state that I'm in for a billionaire's tax and these
are like no you have to vote for the guy who is uh anti-billionaires
tax and you have to like it. It's like shut the up. No, I'm not
going to do that. When are we getting a basketball stream? It's
not happening. Anyway, um these guys are there's like a multitude
of different ideologies at play here. There are the the uh vote
blue no matter who harm reductionist postures. People being like
I'm trans. people being like, "Democrats are going to protect
the undocumented. Democrats are going to protect the trans people."
And it's like, "Democrats have literally written you out of existence."
Okay, they have. Yes, it's better overall under Democratic governance,
Democratic leadership to be a trans person than a uh than a trans
person under a Republican leadership where you like genuinely
have to leave your [__] state. Same with just being
a woman in general living in a [__] red state. But
this kind of like, "Oh, sweetie, you don't care about my marginalized
identity ass bullshit." Especially to someone like myself who
regardless of my, you know, white sis head background, I've never
shied away from my advocacy for trans people and all marginalized
people. You're a [__] idiot. You're a [__]
dumbass. Okay, you're a [__] dumbass. Like, and it
doesn't work. >> That's bad. That's bad optics from him.
But he
he's committed in these ways, which is very funny.
I couldn't do it. I couldn't be like, I'm gonna, you know, I
I couldn't just keep saying stuff like this because I think it
like works out better in the end.
It's It's rough, man. He uh he's like committed in a way where
he he'll say something and he's like, "This is better if I say
this." And I'm like, "Bro, I don't think you believe that." Like,
I genuinely don't believe that he thinks that he would vote for
a third party in a Vance versus Newsome matchup. I just don't
believe it, man. >> And it's annoying. And uh and and all
you're doing is just being like, "You're not moral for me." Okay.
>> But he'll eat all of the hate from saying good luck
with JD Vance presidency, you know.
We can't be doing this same old business as usual politics. It's
very clear.
>> Oh, he said it. Okay, never mind. He did. I was going
to say he like he does this a lot where he in like certain situations
he'll say something
and he'll like stand on it. I'm like, dude, I would never stand
on that. I'm never standing 10 tone 10 toes down with those civilians
getting captured. >> Okay, it's very clear. It's clear
to the voters, too. And that's ironically what I keep trying
to explain. But these guys who are either chorusbacked or whatever,
I don't know what the this guy's deal is, but there's so many
of these who mobilize against the left harder than they mobilize
against the right, by the way.
Okay?
Like they're all up in arms right now on Twitter. They're all
up in arms. Let's have the conversation now two years out before
having the conversation right on the dial. Okay? I'm willing
to have that conversation. I know other people are not. I know
other people are too like focused on some other. But it is seemingly
a chorus. Another one. Bro, you have to switch these cores. Yeah,
it's just some of these guys are straight up like uh you know
in the cult. Like this one is literally in the cult of Destiny.
I know for a fact, right? I've seen this guy before.
>> I don't know who that is. I I'll be honest. I feel like
I should know the people who are DG aligned. No idea who this
is. >> Um but all they do is talk about how I am not really
a Democrat. I am not a part of the Democratic party.
Whether you like it or not, whether you like it or not, we're
in it together, big dog. If you [__] hate the Republicans,
which I don't think you do, let's be real. Then you need to shut
the [__] up and listen to what we're saying. Okay?
I think it needs to be pointed out that Hud's whole goal of pushing
the Hassanabi actually hates the Dem Party is to isolate you
from influencing anything the Dems do to put himself in a position
to be paid by the Dems. Yeah, but it's not going to work because
I still talk to the Democrats. You want to know why? Because
adult Democrats under stand that there is a massive audience
of voters here and >> well I Democrats understand that
at minimum their play should be we just pay lip service to this
guy right we're not going to we're not going to say oh I don't
care about your opinion cuz that's
the only reason you do that is because you think you can make
hay out of it on the internet that's that's why you do that okay
like I don't know that it means a a ton that Democrats talk to
him
They they will like pay lip service to anybody. That's what any
politician does, by the way. They will say, "Hey, yeah, here's
where we agree. Here's where I think you would like like my platform."
And I like you. I want your voters to come vote for me. Can we
work together on on talking through some politics?
That's literally what it's all about. Okay? No politician is
ever going to go and do this is only something you see performative
influencers do. I hate you. NEVER. NEVER TALK ABOUT MY party
ever again. Leave my party now. never speak to me or my party
ever again. It's only proportive online people who do that [__]
>> Not only is there a massive audience of voters here,
but also we're right. Like our advocacy is correct. It's not
just like a a difference in opinion here. Like there are a lot
of people who are
Yeah. I'm not a party loyalist at all. The only the only thing
I care about is advancing an agenda. an agenda that >> well
I will also say we were doing Hutch content okay on this exact
issue of him being performative about this way before Hassan
picked it up and started talking back at Hutch okay so I don't
want to hear any excuses of like oh well Hassan's on this side
and Jay talks taking Nope shut up we're snarking on Hutch way
back months and months ago okay shut up >> that helps the
working class that's >> that's just a genuine passion okay
it's just genuine passion >> an agenda that will destroy
the Republican party I hate the Republican
Okay, I hate the Republican party. I don't want to concede to
the Republicans on policy. I don't like the closeness of a lot
of establishment dems to the
You literally just have to point them to Zoron to see what you
want a Democrat and how you supported them from the beginning.
Exactly. But it doesn't matter. They're literally like, "No,
we love Zoron more than you now."
And the problem is half of these
Twitter squirrel going after us on these core givers is so frustrating.
Stop bringing up Twitter squirrel, okay? Utterly irrelevant in
the grand scheme of things. Please, I'm not going to have a conversation
about the Twitter squirrel.
>> Okay. A a
the third way liberals are fighting back in the UK, too. They're
using aggressively. It's a desperate >> the Twitter squirrel
>> act of a corrupt cabal. I don't
>> Like I don't understand. I mean, I do understand it
to a certain degree, but it's just like unimaginably frustrating
to have to deal with this. But I guess we have to deal with it.
We have to we have to push back on this stuff and we have to
communicate to these people that like their way is dead. Okay,
their way is [__] dead. By the way, dude, are you
leaving for Canada tonight for brief personal news? No, I'm not
even doing personal news. There is no personal news to be had.
I worked out this morning and I'm angry. Okay, I'm also working
on going to Cuba. Okay,
>> I said last month and I'm saying it this month that
we need to start treating leftists like followers the same way
we treat their MAGA counterparts. Centers would rather lose every
election then stop punching left and you wonder why we hate you.
You hoes have been enabling evil since Reagan. Okay, dude. Dearborn.
All my homies hate Dearbornne.
Your mom is a hoe. Your opinion has no value. Read the gift.
You're an idiot. Exactly. Hey man, real quick. Who ran as a third
party candidate in New York City Mars? The demmonds candidate
or the Hassan endorsed one. Let's go. More context of what you
actually said that then the clip that spread >> enthusiastically
crawl through 10 ft of concrete for all of the marginalized >> Do
you feel like the Democrats know that and that's why they get
away with their
>> That's why that's what I mean. So I'm like I I don't
even I don't even entertain that stuff especially this far out
from an election. But even in the primary season, that's immediately
the conversation. It's like, well, whoever is the candidate,
you're gonna vote for them, right? And you know what's really
indecent about that, too? They never returned the favor for left
flank >> This is right after the clip that uh that's on
the the clip that's going around. Right after that, >> no
one ever made, hey, about uh Bernie Sanders potentially becoming
the candidate and and all of the articles that came out about
how Trump might be more preferable to Bernie Sanders cuz they
were writing those. liberals were writing those articles talking
about how you know the head of Goldman Sachs who was like I'm
a lifetime Democratic party voter. I think uh you know Donald
Trump is better than Bernie Sanders >> would enthusiastically
crawl through 10 ft of concrete for all of the marginalized people.
>> Do you feel like the Democrats know that and that's
why wasn't this bound to pay wall as well? No, this is on I've
had it. We went on I've had it and Jen asked me this question
and I told her what I have been saying um every single primary
season and uh I will continue saying it and it doesn't really
matter because
it doesn't really matter. You can cry all day every day. You
can work aggressively to try to cast me aside as an outsider,
as someone who is like trying to ruin the Democratic party's
chances. Ironically enough,
[laughter] um this was where the clip started. Okay. Uh, I'm
gonna I'm gonna blast off right now, uh, real quick and then
we're going to get into this real quick and then we're going
to talk about the Epstein uh, defense that's taking place. Um,
you got to accept that there's nothing to understand here. Some
people are addicted to losing and they believe they deserve nothing.
It's how a woman with low self-esteem in an abusive relationship
struggles to leave the abuser. I mean, maybe, but
these clips of Assan taking this position over the years. This
isn't new.
Yeah, I wouldn't think it's new. Uh, let's see. This is the Dan
tweet. I saw Dan tweet some of these. Yeah, it is Dan tweeting
it. Let's go. Let's see. We got the old Dan tweet right here.
Let's go. >> So, if Joe Biden got the got the nomination
and is running in against President Trump, you would not vote
for >> I don't know. I I've I've honestly considered uh
moving up into the mountains and living an anarchal primitivist
lifestyle of Joe Biden uh becomes the Democratic nominee.
>> Does Dan realize that he might be like helping Hassan
with this? Like
did uh did Hassan,
let me just ask, did Hassan in 2020,
did he vote for Joe Biden,
cuz Dan might Dan might really be undoing his own here?
if he votes for the people when he says this, then it sort of
proves that this is posturing. This is literally just
All you have to do is find where Hassan voted for the person.
I mean, if you don't want to count Kamla because you don't know
that he voted for Kamla,
right? He said he voted for Kamla or whatever, but I some people
don't believe that. >> But it's the whole point is they're
not the same. I think of the DACA kids Supreme Court. Shut the
up. Shut the up. Shut your stupid liberal mouth. Okay. Shut the
up. I don't want to I don't want to hear a single goddamn stupid
peep from people who are like Dhaka kids. Think of the Dhaka
kids. Think of the [__] Supreme Court. Was this when
Hassan was hiding his power level and nobody knew that he was
a leftist? Suck my [__] >> That's the narrative
I hear all the time. We didn't know Hassan was a left. We didn't
know he was like a leftist, guys. We didn't know he's like a
communist. We didn't know that. We thought he was like a sock
dem. >> We are not We This is It's over. I'm done. When
I hear this When I hear this dumbass argument over and over again,
it literally makes me not want to participate in this at all
and urge all of my followers not to vote for Joe Biden either.
Okay. You are pushing me to a point where with your idiocy where
I literally want to do like an an irresponsible thing in your
point of view. Okay. Okay. There's a bunch of clips of Hassan
basically saying I don't like the establishment Democrats.
I I would just encourage people to say like what do you disagree
with here? You know what I'm saying? like he he's basically arguing
that
if you say that you're not loyal, you know, based on just because
there's a crisis happening that you still want to vote for somebody,
not necessarily somebody who's like just you somebody you have
to settle for or don't agree with or don't
Like you can't just have a crisis happening and say, "Okay, now
vote for like Hitler minus 1%." Hitler exists, so vote for Hitler
minus 1%. It's worse than that, right? There's a bigger difference
between JD Vance and Gavin Newsome. But I'm saying that's the
argument he's making is like you can't just take Hitler and then
go like Hitler minus 1%. Anyway, okay, we continue
like the Democrat brand. I don't care about the Democratic party
as a party. I care about policies. I care about them being an
actual counter oppos an actual opposition party to the fascism
that's coming from the Republicans. Okay, that's what I care
about. I care about advancing an agenda that will help the American
working class. I care about advancing an agenda that will roll
back American militarism around the globe. I don't care. I will
work with anyone to get that across, but obviously I can't get
that across with the Republicans at all because I despise them.
They're reactionary and they're not even remotely interested
in that. Okay? They're not they're not interested in that at
all. But it's very very frustrating that these dumb asses, some
of them are dumb. Some of them are are are cynical. Some of them
are getting paid. Cannot comprehend that reality. They there's
just like no difference in opinion here. It's my way the [__]
my way. And they're just yelling to their own echo chamber. They're
yelling to their own echo chamber. Unfortunately, the echo chamber
has elected representatives in it and their uh and their own
consultants. >> Why hasn't Hassan run for local office?
I assume he doesn't want to run for local office.
My first guess would be I don't think he wants to run for local
office. Would you do you have a different guess, Drew, on why
he might not have run for local
we're getting stomped on by fascism. These like uh diet right-wing
libs are just uh uh hitting their left flank. I do suspect a
little bit of here because like they are so united. They are
so goddamn united. Uh and they are so aggressive it almost feels
like there was a boss call being made on chorus or something.
And I don't know because guess who I also talk to? [laughter]
Like guess who I'm you know sometimes at events with Brian Tyler
Cohen. I see him at those events. I don't know what his like
personal opinion against someone like myself is, but like there
is a there is a connect. >> I could just see like I I don't
think there'd be like a call from Chorus. I really don't. Um
I know that's maybe that's people think that's cope and maybe
it is cope. What I could see is you probably have a lot of these
lib type people in chorus. I wouldn't be shocked if they share
group chats together. I wouldn't be shocked if they were like
this song guy in those group chats. Do you know what I mean?
Like of their own accord. Not in a way that's like directed top
down from chorus like here's your messaging on
Right.
I I just think a lot of these people talk and a lot of these
people share the same opinion on Hassan >> tissue here.
So I don't know why the these chorus guys are coming after me
so goddamn hard. Midas touch too. Yeah. This is so funny bro.
Looks like the Kamala headquarter 67 Labuba Dubai checks went
out. Yeah. It's crazy. They like they they just flat out went
they just flat out went as aggressively as possible. We need
to start educating people on who the Newsome is. [sighs] Look
at Jen and Austin. Why are they bringing up the idea of voting
for Gavin? It's because the priority is being right. The best
way to beat the left is go left. Zoron proves it. No, but these
but Jen and Austin love Zoron. They love the left. They would
never turn around and and demonstrate any sort of like ideological
zealatry
>> I also think an election in New York is not really a
road map for the entire country. Obviously >> the against
the left position. >> Give me one second. I know them.
I know them. Listen, I love them. They're fantastic. back >> and
this conversation like um a lot of people are though Hana they
vote in the primaries but they agree with us so we don't even
need to talk about this dumb All I'm saying is all I'm saying
is that most people are like Jen okay most people are like Jen
where they're like I will vote for whoever but I also recognize
that the left position especially in the primary structure is
the is the popular position right that's it but you still advocate
to play for that party you're going to get Gavin big dog ain't
nothing you can do about it exactly so you don't care about beating
the dems you are coping Oh, shut up. Shut up. Shut up. I despise
some of you uh leftists so much. Like, you are so stupid. Please.
I know. I know. I try to maintain a big tent here to the best
of my ability, but some of you literally literally cannot stop
yourselves from being like, I'm morally righteous. It's a bourgeoa
electoral system. Okay. Both of the parties are liberal capitalist
parties. Yes, I know. I know you're not smart. You're not smart
for revealing something that I've been saying for the past 10
years. Okay. The idea that we've already accepted Gavin Newsome
as our uh as our as our candidate is also so stupid, so silly.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is. But it a little bit. Although it's
Mike, it's it's just funny to me cuz like Hassan for all of his
people
can't seem to see that he is a microcosm of the issue he presents
to the liberals, the the DNC establishment, right? He himself
deals with a microcosm of that, right? His stream has all these
like lefties who are like, "You're not you're not going hard
enough, Assan. You're not like socialist enough. You're not communist
enough. You're not pushing the theory enough. You're not Hassan.
Hassan, why are you accepting AOC? Hassan, AOC is a liberal.
She's a li Hassan is very funny to me. >> Vote for Gavin
Newsome even though I think he's duplicitous, a hypocrite, a
thirst trap, hungry for power. All of the things that you say
and harms [clears throat] the Democratic party and sets the psychological
soil to be more. >> Yeah. Central Committee is my fascism.
All of that I agree with. But there are so many young queer black
>> No. Do you live in California? Is that context not relevant
to this conversation? No. That's that's copout. That's a copout.
Okay. Me living in California is a copout. I have a massive audience.
They don't just live in California. Many of them are going to
vote blue no matter who regardless. I'm not going to like urge
them not to vote blue no matter who regardless. But I will never
tell them to do that in the primary. Okay? And I will depending
on the candidate and depending on their platform, I will either
choose to endorse or choose to not endorse. Having said that,
I will never endorse a Republican. I will never tell people to
go and vote for a Republican. I will always push back against
Republican the Republican agenda. Okay?
You're all adults. You can make up your own mind. But I think
it's a copout to just be like, "Oh, you're living in California,
so it doesn't matter." Is >> because my commentary is not
just staying in the state of California. My commentary expands
beyond the state of California. So there is truth to what >> No,
we're going to do the Pam body stuff after this turn around and
go, "Oh, Hassan, you command a massive audience. Why the [__]
won't you?" >> Hello, Rodivus Prime. Thank you for the
five gifted. I'll add the time in just a second here, guys. We're
off to a good start. We're off to a good start. We haven't done
the pan bondi stuff yet. We're going over this Hassan tweet and
uh people seething about it.
The not Hassan tweet, the Hassan clip getting for Kla Harris
in the same way that I did for Hillary Rodm Clinton. In the same
way that I did for Joe Biden. And yet even back then they would
yell and say we weren't sufficiently pro Joe Biden. We weren't
sufficiently proary Clinton. That the Bernie bros somehow cooked
the books. Even though many of those people have realized
many of those people have now realized Bernie was right. Bernie
would have been the [__] candidate to be Donald Trump
in 2016. We wouldn't have had all this heartache. And yet they
still can't expand on that concept. They still can't comprehend.
In any case, yeah, it's almost reflexive for Democrats on here
to blame professional lefties for every time the party fails,
but where the party has been atrophying votes among workers who
don't follow politics closely and have vaguely moderate politics.
Go back to Blue Sky if you think moderates where I live will
vote for Gavin Newsome, you can't handle reality. There is truth
to this as well. And by the way, moderate politics uh or vaguely
moderate politics doesn't even mean that they would like hate
someone like uh Zoramani or hate someone like Bernie Sanders.
Okay, that's the irony here. A lot of people think that these
people are making decisions on on ideology, ideological goals,
policy goals. They're not. That's the reason why people think
Bernie Sanders, Republicans think Bernie Sanders is more of a
is more of a centrist than Kla Harris is. It's just about who
likes. It's just about who which politician you like.
The Twitter conversation is disconnective in the real world.
Moderates are not lining up to vote for
Uh well, that's what I'm assuming is basically when he goes back
and says, "Oh, I like hate this person. I'm not voting for them.
then he does vote for them. It's like, okay, well, I mean, he's
kind of just showing you that it's pretty obvious he's um
I don't know. It's pretty obvious what he's doing there. Anyone
and everyone that hyperfocuses on on my assessment here of Gavin
Newsome that's making that hypothetical conversation, vote blue,
no matter who conversation, run into the ground does not realize
that they have lost it.
[__] doesn't care about marginalized communities.
The guys in this picture. Yeah. The guy who posted this literally
has Bill Clinton in his [__] profile
He's like double double invested in. It's crazy to me, bro. Bill
Clinton definitely didn't any kids. Okay. I like Bill Clinton's
too cool to [__] kids. All right. Just verifiably,
obviously, Bill Clinton's way too cool to [__] kids.
He probably went to that island cuz he does, but he not [__]
kids on that island. Okay.
I'm just saying. >> I went to college with the girl you
were fighting on the timeline. Stop talking to her when she took
an internship at the Koch Foundation. Yeah, so many of these
people are operatives here. I'll give you a great example, okay,
with Gavin Newsome. What would it take for me to actually vote
for Gavin Newsome? Cuz I know that there's >> talk about
the policies. I'm just looking for like a little bit more. >> I
was wondering why some of us on the left are so opposed to allowing
political arsonists like Hassan and his ilk into the tent. I
mean, he's in the tent already. Look at look at how much I hate
these other leftists to my to my left flank. I don't do that.
You want to know why I don't do that? Cuz it's okay because the
left in this country have no real power. So all those guys, whether
it be bad empanada, whether it be squirrel or whether it be like
random small communist content creators are like, "Oh, well Assan
is problematic for this reason or that reason." He's a sheep
dog for the Democratic party. I don't care. Yeah, go ahead. Whatever.
I'm always going to punch up. I'm not going to [__]
punch down.
>> Okay.
I mean, hold on. What did he just say? Wasn't he just calling
the squirrel mentally ill?
Wasn't he literally just calling the squirrel mentally ill two
seconds ago? >> Sheep dog bad empanada. Whether it be squirrel
or whether it be like random small communist content creators
are like, "Oh, well Asan is problematic for this reason or that
reason. He's a sheep dog for the Democratic party. I don't care.
Yeah, go ahead. Whatever. I'm always going to punch up. I'm not
going to [__] punch down."
>> He just called her mentally ill like 10 minutes ago.
>> Very funny.
[laughter]
legit communist newspaper. >> That's cope. That's cope.
Uh he didn't go out of his way to say though he was replying
to the squirrel group. We have passed out so many newspapers
that we surpass your influence among the Turk men. You mad, bro?
I'm so mad. >> Well, yeah, I know the squirrel is insane.
I know the squirrel's obviously insane. I just thought it was
funny that he listed her in the examples of people he doesn't
punch down on cuz it's punching left and he doesn't do that.
And like literally when he heard that they'd made comments, he
was like, "That person's mentally ill."
I just find it funny. That's all. simply find it funny. >> The
course call you a 1% while they make 8K a month for posting one
on Tik Tok a week that gets 150 likes. Dark money donors wasting
cash on a less effective best orbiter daily quest for free. I
K-pop influencer going after you too. I know. I know. I know.
We're going to talk about that too. Hold on. I got smoke for
every single one of these today because it all comes back to
this. The Democratic Party favorability. Okay.
They don't want to answer this question. Why is the Democratic
Party unfavorability right now at 64% and only growing?
Why? Donald Trump is the president. Donald Trump is a allegedly
Donald Trump is defending not allegedly. We know he's defending
Donald Trump has a neo-Nazi brigade that is unaccountable, that
is Americans in the suburbs. Donald Trump has not fixed the economy.
Donald Trump is incredibly unpopular and yet the Democrats unpopity
has only grown in that time frame. One must ask the question,
why? Why are the Democrats historically unpopular? One must I
guess >> at a time like this. They have no answer for this
question. They have no answer for this question. I do.
>> I I actually also have no answer for this question.
Is it just general like discontent with the government?
I actually don't know. I'm I'm legitimately like unsure that
I could give you a solid reason on why the Democrats are this
unpopular, why they've continued to grow this unpopular over
time. Some of it I understand right in the aftermath of the election
being like, "Okay, these lied to us about Joe Biden. What the
[__] is this about?" I get it there, but then I don't
get this huge split. What is this
middle of 2024? I don't I don't actually get it. Is this Maybe
this is around the election. Maybe it is around the time
I don't know. I don't know what happened, man. I know why. I
know why. It's because the Democrats are not fighting back sufficiently
against the the Republican party's agenda. That's it. They're
known as the do nothing dems. They're known as the no backbone
Dems. They're known as the Democratic party that has left its
own population behind, its own voters behind. The marginalized
identities that Democrats seemingly only remember to talk about
when it comes like the Dems are doing much to help people right
now. Well, they're kind of powerless. They didn't they lost the
election pretty bad. I don't know what the [__] this
to do >> to [__] uh you know demanding that
people vote unconditionally for vote blue no matter who people
um those marginalized identities have been left behind by the
Democratic party. Okay, that's it. That's it. The most popular
Dems in the country across the board popularity stem from uh
the the you know the more radical Democrats, the Bernie Sanders
of the world, AOCC's of the world, Zoram Mumani.
Why are they so popular? Why are they carrying the Democratic
party's brand currently? The reason why they're carrying the
Democratic Party's brand currently is because they're fighters.
They're fighters. They have loyalty. They have the base. The
base wants more people like that.
Okay, man. I feel bad. I feel bad for the Hassan people in my
comments who are like, "Oh, this is awesome that you're saying
this." Like, I don't think you guys understand what I'm saying.
I'm like, I'm not defending this guy or
I I think people think I'm like defending this guy or the comment.
I I don't think the comment is true. I'm basically just explaining
what I think is actually going on there. Very crazy.
>> These people right now will not. These people are reactionary.
This position is unironically reactionary. They're forcing you
to accept the false binary with the premise of Gavin versus Donald,
which would force you to support the better one if you're rational.
We have to show how irrational it is to force people in the false
binary again, which is the reason why Harris lost. We can and
should ask for something better than Gavin if we want to fix
the conditions that led to Trump. Exactly. That is exactly my
point, which is part of the reason why I responded with libs
don't care about losing to Trump. uh libs who don't care about
losing a Trump now want you to obey in advance of their hypothetical
establishment candidate while there isn't even a guarantee there
will be election two years from now using marginalized people
as a cudgel as Gavin threw trans people under the bus
not only that but I also responded to him directly over here
as well where I said you're in a cult led by a streamer Lamau
the day he goes republican you will too you didn't care when
he boosted Sam Hide Nick Wentz or Lauren Southern don't talk
to me about obeying in advance vote blue no matter who got us
in this mess to which he had the the silliest response how many
I do.
Oh, how many Gerber accounts have you retweeted and signal boosted?
Has that
I'm trying to think. I think Hassan has liked some tweets from
some uh right leaning accounts who are attacking Destiny. Has
he retweeted some? >> He retweeted a signal boosted. Brother,
what are you talking about? Your favorite content creator's mouth
is on top of a neo-Nazis.
>> What do you mean?
I believe that's misinformation. I think that's actually technically
misinformation.
There's no there nobody knows that. Come on, man. What the Why
you Why are you saying that? That's like That's like not even
true, man. >> You retweeted Gropers. Yeah, this guy is
a dwitriter for Destiny. Okay. I don't think I've retweeted any
griper accounts, but it's so Are you not boys with Michael from
Pay anymore? Where did you get this idea from? Assange disagrees
with Mike on a lot of stuff. Okay. on like little things like
whether or not Emirou was intentionally cooking up an op to try
to get [laughter] try to like Han or something. That was pretty
that was pretty skits. Okay.
>> Why can't the Republicans in Congress think for themselves?
Why are they just going along with Trump?
I have to pick Destiny or Hassan. No, I'd rather not. I'd actually
rather just have my channel die than than swear loyalty to one
of these two people. I'd rather just I'd rather just like, you
know, try to enter that job market such as it is right now, which
basically is just saying I'm I'd rather be unemployed. Okay.
I'd rather risk the job market such as it is. The the like
Amazonian River with a thousand piranhas that have been starving
for a week in it. That job market. Okay. I'd rather risk that
right now than like swear blind loyalty to one of these people.
>> Trump's lova. Yeah. They are so internet brain. They
think like white guy that is consistently trying to be edgy uh
and and consistently saying slurs is the best most viable Democrat
of all time. No man, that polit that politics of that sort is
repulsive to the average person. You might actually think in
your hug box that Hassan [__] represents uh Mauist
China. Okay? He represents communism. He represents the USSR.
This is like an utterly repulsive version of politics. True to
the average American that is uninitiated, utterly oblivious to
what like socialism communism looks like. >> Machar bogs
people. It's cuz he's like the only person who even does like
an hour of work a week going on CNN. Every one of those people
on CNN is just like cashing in a favor from somebody else
and every one of them is totally uninformed and totally they're
like actually embarrassing to watch. He's like he's just like
um
yeah, anybody who's remotely read up on these on this stuff like
Beasley, Josiah, um Pisco, all these people go on those same
programs and totally eviscerate people. The people in those programs
are just like
they're they're literally like at the end of their careers cashing
in favors to get that job. >> Yes, that is repulsive
when we're talking about the electoralist agenda.
I'm not running mauists. Okay. I want people like to
>> He doesn't give a [__] about people of color.
He doesn't give a [__] about >> I mean or you
could just, you know, use your brain.
There's like an option actually. You could you could literally
just use your
I I know it's hard. I know it's really hard for people. I know
they desperately want me to come on here and tell them like exactly
what to do and think so that they can pretend they're invested
in politics, but I'm just telling them what to do and think and
they never have to make a decision for themselves and I can basically
be like their god. I know that's what a lot of people come here
for, but I'm not going to do that. I have no interest in doing
that. It's
so I'm going to go ahead and just say you can make a decision
there yourself and we cover drama most of the time. >> Oh,
shut up, white boy. Suck my white boy. You didn't give a [__]
about Gaza. Okay. And Kla Harris lost. And when Kla Harris lost
to Donald Trump again, Donald Trump actually did unlimited unlimited
violence to these marginalized identities. I hate these mother,
man. They wear they wear black and brown people like a shield.
It's so dumb.
The only the only time these mother go, we shouldn't do identity
politics. We shouldn't do identity politics. And then they immediately
deploy it to their left flank. We know what's up at this point.
>> Oh, the points of sounds. Gotcha. >> We know what's
up. Fair enough.
Reducing care for marginalized communities to a single hypothetical
vote misunderstands how political engagement works. The premise
here is that political morality is measured exclusively at the
voting booth while also claiming it proves he exploits marginalized
people for profit. We all know that Assan spent years directing
money, attention, and platform power towards those communities.
If the standard for caring about marginalized people is unconditional
support for whichever major party candidate is on the ballot,
then you're redefining care in a way that conveniently excludes
any form of political action outside of party loyalty. >> That's
actually a pretty smart way of phrasing that, right? It's essentially
saying like
doing anything that with the status quo such as it is is actually
you're actually trying to like trans people. It's like dude that's
for and you'd only say that if you are benefiting from the status
quo
and by the way I don't necessarily think like you know what Hassan's
ideal government is. I'm pretty sure I would like that less than
what the status quo is to be honest with you. But I'm just saying
I understand he's not like an irrational actor in the things
he's >> These guys want to turn. These guys want to turn
the base of support and the base of loyalty in the Democratic
party to the MAGA cult. Okay? And they're doing it at a time
when there is a tremendous amount there is a tremendous amount
of energy directed towards
there's a tremendous amount of energy directed towards demanding
more from the Democrats. There is a lot of enmity for the Democrats
right now. And the reason for why there's a lot of enmity to
for the Democrats right now, as I keep repeating over and over
again, 64% disapproval, 33.9%
approval. The reason why this exists is because the Democrats
are not doing it. Okay? They're not doing it. They're not they're
not leaning in to the demands of the base. They're not even doing
like the hashtag resistance liberalism of 2016
people. He doesn't give a [__] about preventing fascists
from winning elections. All he cares about at the end of the
day is clout and money. If Republicans created a leftwing plan
to cause spread voter apathy and discourage people from voting
against them, it would look just like a sunper. If you're curious
what I'm referencing,
>> literally all you'd have to do is ignore him. I'm tell
I'm telling you if you just ignored him, if you didn't draw all
this attention to him, you wouldn't even be wouldn't cause apathy
at all. You just say, "Well, that's some some crazy people over
there." >> Here's a clip from the most recent podcast that
Hassan [__] just went on.
>> I would probably third party. >> You would? >> Oh,
yeah. I mean, at that point, it doesn't even matter. >> If
you can't see the difference between >> If Gavin Newsome
wins, if Gavin Newsome wins the primaries, at that point it doesn't
[__] matter. We're cooked. 90 likes, please skip
this, man. Shut your ass up. If I'm looking at something, [laughter]
there's a reason for it. Okay? If I'm looking at >> Hassan,
Hassan, did you know that Van Bondi was testifying before Congress?
I don't care about this. These people don't I don't care if these
people don't like you. Can you just play the politics? Just play
the video. Just play the Don't play this. I don't care about
this guy. Just play the video.
B that chatter immediately. >> There's a reason for it.
Shut the up. Okay. He just posted this an hour ago. This will
do. Guess what? You want to watch that video? You want to watch
that video? You go watch that video. Okay, you know you know
how to use YouTube. Go watch the video. I'm not doing the video
right now. >> Numbers on TikTok. I don't think you guys
understand. Left bashing right now is absolutely the fashion
for the Democratic Party aligned consultant class and the people
that are desperately trying to get a bag from either chorus or
from the liberal Democratic Party aligned consultant class. These
guys are putting their flag on the ground right now at this moment.
Okay, stop backseat producing my stream.
Some of them are doing it for an $8,000 check. Some of them are
doing it because they want to get the $8,000 check down the line.
[laughter]
Sorry. I just find it very funny.
This is I just find it funny that this happens no matter the
size you are as a stream. Okay? No matter what size your stream
is, this happens to you no matter what. Okay? People are going
to come in and they're going to be like, "Hey,
just so you know, I don't like what you're doing right now. I
just want to I just want to hop in, get into chat, and say, "I
don't like your stream right now." It's like, dude, I don't know
how to tell you this, but permanently banned. Get the out of
here. It's ironic because Jen, after this clip ended, agreed
with me.
Because Jen understands that that vote blew no matter who. That
vote blue no matter who mentality is what got us here. Okay,
you're brain breaking yourself on sub 100 viewer Andes for your
mental health. Skip these losers. I can't imagine what he's going
to say to this person. They spammed it twice. I can't imagine
the horrible things he's going to say to this person who's been
following since 2021. Subscribed for 3 months. Okay.
>> Horrible things and really reconsider why I'm actually
talking about this. This person >> only an hour off. That's
too kind. >> Utterly irrelevant in the grand scheme of
things. Their opinions are utterly irrelevant. They are trying
they are trying to actively stake the Democratic
party's attitude. Okay. Because they think the Democrats are
going to listen. It's like I don't even think they fight harder
against this. Like I I do think, you know, outside of Hutch,
I think most of these people
I do think they cover MAGA more. It's just that like the charity
they have for Hassan makes no sense, right? Like the things they
say about Hassan make no sense to me. Like they're so blown out
of proportion. And so while they don't spend the majority of
their time covering Hassan, I'd never accuse them of that. I
do think like their opinions on them are so blown out of proportion
they baffle me sometimes.
Like even from this one clip, I do think it's like to me it's
very goofy to take the clip this way.
Well, one, it's like kind of clipped out of context to >> someone
like myself a little too hard.
>> Just saying it's like him not caring about marginalized
communities. I just thought that was >> I want that to
happen. Yeah, Gavin Newsome is not even in the running right
now. My theory, the faces of woke one were all liberals. You're
the faces of woke two and the liberals are desperate to have
someone actually leftwing to have mainstream relevance. Is it
a coincidence that this is exactly what the right is saying about
Fuentes to a certain degree.
Is this person confirmed to de-orbiter?
It's um it is exactly what Fuentes does though, right? like they
do serve almost the exact same purpose as in here's here's what
they're doing. They have a lot of influence. They have a ton
of viewership. They have the cultural ear of a of a huge portion
of the party. Okay? They they like are a cultural force for the
party. And so
what they both do is they try to use that power the the cultural
power they have to move the party in a direction. Asold does
this too. Lots of people do,
And so they will say things like, "I don't I don't like this.
I'm never going to what is it?" Nick Fentes is literally like
organizing to primary people in the Republican party right now,
right? To try to like run primaries or just like work against
these people. I think he's working against Vivc in Ohio, right?
Directly.
Like they are they're explicitly attempting to do this. It's
because they want the party to move more in their direction.
They don't think the party is serving their interests and they're
like, "Okay, I'm going to make it like literally pay attention
to me. I have more power than you think."
No, I'm not saying that in terms of like quote unquote unhingedness,
it's the same. I'm saying that size-wise they're about the same
in their effect, right? They're trying to move the party in a
certain direction. I'm not saying that like Hassan is equal to
Fuentes is that he's as, you know, outside the norm in terms
of his social beliefs as Fentes. That's not the case. I'm saying
that they serve a similar point. Bad and Pada is not on the scale
of Hassan, Asmin or Fuentes. So including him in this is very
goofy, but I'm you're misharing you're misunderstanding the comparison
anyway. It has nothing to do with how extreme the views are.
It's everything to do with the views being like um not appreciated
by the mainstream and then that the person has more power than
that mainstream party is will the mainstream of that party is
willing to acknowledge.
>> Yes, he is a a part of the Des Bullah Brigades or whatever.
Yeah, I don't know if you saw or covered it, but that account
is a dead bullet mod. For your information, you're retweeting
a moder of Dan moderator of Dan Solman's gangstalking Nazi community
trying to raise awareness since these bad faith fascists are
trying to infiltrate discourse and poison the well against anybody
that's pro Palestine and pro universal healthcare. Yeah, here
it is. He's one of the mods of the Dezba brigades. This is the
type of they post over there. They're literally poor chain gropers,
but liberal and pro-Israel. >> So like not gropers. >> That's
the problem. These people don't
>> these people don't understand. It's it's basically a
neo-Nazi community, you
>> Yeah. Get them out. Kick Islam out of America. This
is the type of [__] that they're posting on there.
Deport the brother. Average Octopi IQ is 73. What is octopi?
I don't even know what that means. Yeah, sand n word. Total sand
n word deaths.
>> Jesus. Disavow that. >> Like this is the type
of [__] that these guys are posting in that. >> Bro,
this guy I didn't realize this guy went off the reservation like
that. I I knew that this guy like hated me a lot. He he would
like fight with me on Twitter all the time. Then he sort of disappeared.
I didn't realize he went like crazy like that. Holy [__]
This Dan's top guy apparently.
Jesus. What the community? And then they try to act like they're
actually woke or progressive or
are we calling pro-Israel groups neo-Nazis? Well, I think it's
like in essence they're, you know, supporting ethnostates to
the detriment of like marginalized groups, maybe something along
those lines, >> or or liberal in any capacity. Ironically
enough, these are the infiltrators.
Okay.
These are the infiltrators. This is Destiny's community. Okay.
And there are so many No, no, no. Hassan doesn't understand.
That's Dan Saltman's community. It has nothing to do with Destiny
at all. It actually is Dan Saltman's community purely and it
has no no connection to Destiny whatsoever. Actually, does Hassan
not know that? That like Destiny and Dan, they they never talk.
They're not connected in any way. Why would Hassan say that?
dumb out there who get deliluded into thinking either because
they're going to get a $8,000 bag here. So many dumb out there
who think these guys actually are on their side. Okay, this is
Pestany's
>> Brown marginalized people in red states. And even though
this corporate Democrat is you see it in a long-term game, in
the short-term game a >> you aren't communist enough for
me. I'm unfollowing. Okay, go ahead.
>> President Nome over a president [laughter] term game.
in the short game. Let me watch that again. >> You aren't
communist enough for me. I'm unfollowing. Okay.
Following since January 27th.
>> Okay, go ahead.
>> Permanently banned. >> President Newsome over
President JD V. >> Get out.
That was sarcastic, right? I don't know if that was sarcastic.
No, that's there are a bunch of people who are like that. >> Substance.
This is what I meant when I said it's usually trying to reach
these people. Even knowing that a Vance presidency will be a
continuation of the current admin. He still wouldn't vote Blue
no matter who. These people are just as bad as most diehard maggots.
Okay.
Anyway, I said, uh, this guy, uh, you know, repost, uh, all this
racist, he's a racist, obviously. Uh, he is an insane person,
and none of them actually have any interest in like helping,
uh, defeat the Republicans at all. They're just doing their own
petty
personal grievance politics. >> Demon Bama still exist.
>> Look at the suggestions. You might like this guy. >> Yeah,
I don't think you like this guy. >> Although curious that
they get put together. little little curious >> like helping
defeat the Republicans at all. They're just doing their own petty
[__] uh personal grievance politics. Ironically enough,
Jennifer is not one of these people, right? And neither is Austin.
These are my friends. These are people that I've known for years.
And they are trying to relitigate Vote Blue no matter who politics
on the timeline. And it's giving the game away because Gavin
Newsome is not even the candidate, right? And if you listen to
the rest of the conversation that they cut out >> but enthusiastically.
>> Yeah. When we listen to this already
mother was a landlord calls a terrorist for completing mandatory
conscription dodge mandatory military service in Turkey. Like
their only politics is
okay.
Their only politics is like fasan. They have no real interest
in changing this country. They have no real interest in combating
the republicans.
Um anyway, so he followed up on this and said, "For those of
you wondering why some of us on the left are so opposed to allowing
political arsonists like Assan and his ilk into the tent, the
replies on this thread agreeing with Assan is a perfect explanation
as to why we think that they'd rather hand this country over
to people like JD Vance and Peter Theo whose only goal is to
take our democratic system out back behind the barn and put down
rather than vote for a Democrat who is in 100% align with their
beliefs. This person is not on the left. He's lying to people.
The reason people like Assan and his fans think that way is because
the majority of them are rich and white, thus unaffected by the
disastrous policies enacted by the GOP. Boom. Hit the identity
politics line once again. guy who has been calling me a Islamist
terrorist radical fundamentalist for maintaining the majority
position on Israel is turning around and being like he's a white
guy. He's a white guy. He doesn't care. He's out of touch white
guy. Gavin Newsome hasn't won the primary yet. Okay. And I don't
think he will. I I will say it's hard to work against, you know,
h
the Israel thing does like catastrophic damage to all these people,
especially like this guy. Now, I would say Hassan also has to
deal with the points in general, right? You can't just you can't
just point to this guy being bad faith and saying sorry and say
well you shouldn't listen to this guy he's really bad faith you
should be able to contend with the points as well but to me the
the Israel issue is where Hassan gets like a bunch of credibility
back now every he was getting on for the Israel thing he lost
sponsors for the Israel thing and at the end of the day it seems
like we've all come to the same opinion that like oh Israel was
going way too hard and we probably should have seen the warning
signs and a lot of the people who were flashing the warning signs
kinds. Maybe they weren't anti-Semitic. Maybe that was like actually
something we should have paid attention to. And people like this
who totally denigrated that, who totally like made light of that
the whole time.
I think they look a lot worse in retrospect. I think Hassan gets
a lot of like non virtue signaling clout. It would it would be
easy to um or maybe like non
clucking to the mainstream opinion clout there. Like I I think
standing on that looks really good for you in retrospect.
>> That's my opinion.
Uh Myra, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank >> And even if he was, he would be one
of the few individuals who could lose the [__] JD
Vance. A lot of liberals don't understand this. Okay, they are
still >> Yeah, I don't I don't think Gavin Newsome would
lose third neoliberalism when it's died already. I said these
people are not on the left and anyone who agrees with them is
either being paid by the dems or being duped. They work for a
pedal Twitch streamer who has collabed with and platform Nazis.
They are pro-Israel and anti Medicare for all. I can't believe
I called Destiny a Twitch streamer. He's not a Twitch streamer.
Um and Anti Medicare for all. They don't care if the Dems lose
to the fascists. Okay. >> Uh he might. No, he won't. I'm
sorry. He >> He's a kick streamer.
>> Yeah. If you want to understand like the most exhaustive
version of this vote, blue no matter who is this. Hutch would
vote for Jeffrey. >> Jeffrey Epste. Yes or no? >> I
do. I do. I do. Yeah. But if he had a Dan next to his name and
he was running >> Oh my god. >> I would probably
vote for him. I'm just >> That'd be a tough one.
>> Oh no. Hutch. Oh no. a lot. >> Not a joke. Not
a joke.
>> this person admitted he used you for engagement. Oh,
I did it because I knew folks like you would easily fall for
it. Easiest trap I've ever said. >> That's not what he
said. You grifter their He didn't say he'd vote third party of
Newsome versus Vance. Didn't know New Vance were the Democratic
and Republican nominees already in 2026, the year of our Lord.
Yeah, he's pretty stupid for answering the idiotic hypothetical.
And you're pretty stupid for making a Tik Tok from him answering
a hypothetical just so you could farm other stupids into thinking
you're not the biggest grifter out here. Oh, I did it because
I knew folks like you would fall for it. >> Angry teenager.
That's a horrible way to
Hassan shouldn't have answered that hypothetical. Well, I only
did this because I knew you would engage with it. I knew it get
me views. Yeah. Speaking of speaking of being a real and answering
questions, Jesus, >> I don't think a lot of these people
realize that a JD Vance Gavin Newsome matchup would cause so
much enmity
would cause so much animosity
that
JD Vance could potentially lose or sorry, Gavin Newsome could
potentially lose to JD Vance.
Yeah, damn, bro. They're even saying you're not hot. I know.
I saw that. Trey Eastston, who is again
who should always be asked why he refused to put who he worked
for in office.
It's John Federman. This is one of the John Federman handlers.
He's neither hot nor cool. His politics are just hate the Democrats.
We should all stop listening to him. This is it. This is the
main point. These guys want desperately for the National Democratic
Party to not move away from them. At least this person gets paid
by the Democrats, right? He's a consultant. many of these other
that are doing the are only doing it because they're fans of
a different content creator. How do I I think this is a bad way
for him to frame this. Just to be clear, I do think this is actually
a horrible way for him to frame it because I think the similarities
between the the groers and and the Destiny community are a lot
there's a lot of similarities. Okay, there's similarities abound.
And I think a lot of people don't even realize that they believe
these things. Not because they're fans of Destiny, but because
like these people are in comment sections everywhere. They're
constantly pushing the same narrative. Like they might not be
aware of Destiny at all. They may think this without being aware
of Destiny at all. So, when you say it's like all because they're
fans of this person, you are very likely or you're liable to
catch somebody who's never watched a Destiny piece of content
and has that opinion based on it being downstream of somebody
watching Destiny's content, right? And so, you're you're basically
you're signaling it's something that they're unaware of. You
sound like you're just coping to them. I think it's probably
strategically bad to do this. The liberal side of the party is
attacking you because we have the power now. They need to kneecap
you for Gavin. Yes. Is it fair to say the ideological divide
between you and them? capitalism versus socialism or is that
an oversimplication? No, it's even it's even dumber than that
because there are plenty of people who aren't socialists that
I work with within the ranks of the Democratic party to accomplish
some of the goals that I have. So the irony there is it's not
even this ideological divide broadly even though that ideological
divide we have the power now. I mean people are treating them
like they have the power, right?
And I I think the Zoron thing, winning against like winning in
an election where you know the the mainstream of the party basically
just supported like an like a third party candidate like a lot
of people who were mainstream Democrats essentially just supported
a third party candidate over Zoron, right?
It's like that's that's unfortunately going to be like a pretty
big wakeup call to a lot of those people who are leftist and
and Democrat associated and they're going to go, "Oh, what the
[__] You just supported this guy. What the what?
What the? WE WON THE P PRIMARY. I thought it was blue no matter
who after the primary. What the happened? WHAT THE HAPPENED TO
BLUE NO MATTER WHO AFTER THE PRIMARY, DOG?
You know what I'm saying? I think now I would say a lot of the
people like the Lib and learn guys mostly got behind Zoron, right?
They'll vote for Zoron over over
not Newsome but uh Quuomo,
you know?
But I think a lot of there were Dems who either didn't endorse
or were like very very heming and hawing or outwardly said like
Zorhan's a Islamist. >> It obviously exists in this circumstance.
It's literally them saying no no we don't want more Zoran manis.
Oh god forbid we get more Zoran manis. That's what it is. >> Where's
this guy going? >> These people are so scared that more
Zora Mani are going to get elected that they would rather burn
the opposition party's already diminished credibility than make
the Dems a real fighting party for the working class.
This is what this conversation is about. Your dog. I know all
of it.
>> Kaya is free. >> There's only one Zoron. It's
much easier to hamstring his agenda and say, "Look, it didn't
work." But there are a bunch of Zorons. People will start to
wake up. Exactly. That's what the real problem is. They are absolutely
terrified. These centrists are absolutely terrified that there
are going there is going to be a wave of candidates.
There is going to be a wave of
uh uh left flank candidates that come out of this midterm battle.
And they are literally bricks right now cuz the primaries are
upon us and they are terrified of that. Okay. They're terrified
of that. These people are so scared that more are going to get
elected that they would rather >> Oh yeah. Another thing
I'm not thinking about this does do this does try to create like
a wedge or creates you know urgency for people to vote for non-socialist
non you know sock dem candidates in primaries right that is another
effect of this is they're trying to run with this to try to push
those candidates to either be you know face stiff competition
in the primary push more donations to their competition in primaries
that would be another like downstream effective of this rhetoric
like this um discourse making this blow up which actually seems
like maybe the most important reason you would try to make it
blow up. So, there is like another reason you'd want to do that.
You want to take this guy and go, "Oh, look, any socialist candidate,
they're going to be really bad for you. Don't vote for them in
the primaries." Actually, if you if you have somebody else running
against in the primaries, you should go vote for them. >> Burn
the What is this? That they would rather burn the opposition
parties already diminished credibility than to make the Dems
the real Oh, [__] The real Oh, yeah. I did that up.
Hold on.
to the best of us, man. Terrible takes >> You know who?
>> Oh,
I'll be honest. Somebody somebody told me that this was like
like this woman cooked in this video and I suspect but I don't
know for sure. I suspect it's going to be massive cope and this
person is going to suck. But I don't know. I I'm interested in
this video being right as an attempted whatever
>> was like, "Oh, she totally cooked this guy who went
after Hassan." I'm like, "Yeah, I doubt it." >> Who have
absolutely no idea are interested in wielding power? You know
who understands using the party as a vehicle to wield power?
The Republicans who keep beating you.
>> And another thing >> I don't I don't think Kmart
and Na Jumba cooked. Okay. I don't think I don't think Kmart
and Nissa cooked here at all. If I had to guess interview and
the terrible takes and meltdowns that >> anyway, let's
start with this dumb first and then we'll get into the commentary.
>> Son [__] who is the world's oldest angry
teenager, just said that if this was a choice, >> dog,
you look this way. You can't say I'm the world's oldest angry
teenager when you look that [laughter] way. Okay. What are you
then? I don't even know what he's saying. >> An even older
variant. Like what the [__] Really?
This is what we're doing today. You can't be looking like that,
man. You can't be looking chopped as
you can't be a chopped unk and be like, "Oh, Islam, the world's
oldest angry >> In 2028, he would vote third party. >> JD
Vance or >> I I think I just shouldn't use, you know, if
I see Clvicular lo using language, I'm like, "Yeah, I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna try it. I think that looks really bad when old
people try to use that language. Okay. I think I it just looks
rough. Mog doesn't count. Mog has been in the lexicon for a long
time. >> Or Gavin Newsome. >> Well, I'd have to vote
for Gavin News. >> I wouldn't blame. What about you? I'd
>> probably vote third party. >> You would? >> Oh
yeah. I mean I at that point it doesn't even matter. >> So
you're telling me one year after the second Trump term where
we've seen Americans profile detained and killed by IC the free
foreign aid because health programs and snap with climate agreements,
the environmental protections, American farmers being forced
to keep with foreign producers the January 6 regime change in
Venezuela the do the circuit. >> Did he just walk away?
Am I the only one reacting to this now? >> A lot more.
But you're telling me that after all that
the same >> just walked away.
>> He just walked away. Now I'm the only person reacting.
I'm the only person transforming. [clears throat] >> It's
all Republicans because he understands better than most of his
comrades the difference between when Republicans are in power
and when Democrats are in power. Watch >> about the Democratic
party. >> But they are our representatives and they're
supposed to represent us and they do have a platform and the
media does listen to them. So, we have to wield them like a weapon
to the best of our ability. We have to use them to also continue
yelling about these things that we care about. >> And it's
clear that he's just here for the engagement. He's only interested
in monetizing the anger that Republicans generate when they're
in power while being a whole ass millionaire Nepo baby cosplaying
as a revolutionary. izing the Republicans generate when they're
in power while being a whole ass. >> I I do get why people
don't like some aspects of this. But I'm sitting here like, "Yeah,
but he went and he like bought a bunch of hand warmers for people.
He's like freezing out and he went out and like filmed at the
protests. He's like actually trying to do some on the ground
stuff now. What do we what do we want this guy to do other than
than die? I just feel like every single person their actual point
is like Hassan needs to die as soon as possible."
Like I like he goes he he does some stuff on the ground and then
he is bad. Yeah. Not have politics. I
yeah sure.
I'm just saying that like the criticisms are how are you supposed
to take the criticism seriously when he like does the opposite
of the criticisms and he gets criticized again?
I don't know. I don't know how you take the criticism seriously
at that point. Right. >> Millionaire Neppo baby cosplaying
as a >> Oh. And then he w he just walked away,
>> Not even. >> Oh, now he's got to now he's got
to rewatch it. Now he's got to react. >> No, we already
watched it. >> You have no agenda. You have no vision.
And you don't mind when the Republicans actually win? >> Well,
it depends on what you mean, Schle. Are the politics are the
people like he advocates for the truest sign of his politics
or the truest sign of his politics the things he said four years
ago on the D program one time? Cuz four years ago on the D program
one time, he was pretty dumb. He had some pretty politics. Okay.
But if we look at the candidates he pushed then if if those are
indicative of his politics then I'm like nah it's not that bad
like it I'm still not they're the people I'd necessarily vote
for but I it's not that >> God damn
your worldview is repulsive to the average person.
You have no policies. Which is why we shouldn't even focus too
much about this. We shouldn't be focusing too much on these like
uh uh on these influencers for the most part. Okay? Because the
influencers are not speaking TO A REAL AUDIENCE. THEY'RE TRYING
TO create an audience. is they're trying to create momentum behind
third-we neoliberalism once again, but they're morons that don't
realize that the real people on the ground want more and that
is reflected in the polls. Godamn, you're 50 years old, but you
have the understanding of the you have the the politics understanding
of a [__] 10-year-old. Every single time they're
like, "These Bernie bros, these Bernie
This country is an insane asylum because what do you mean? You're
already demanding people swear vote to some corporate [__]
almost 3 years from now. I'm personally of the belief that we
won't have anything resembling a country or elections by then.
But even if we do, I know how you see the Dems give Nazis every
single thing they want and think somehow continue to do that
saves us from this nightmare. A bunch of these people doing this
exact thing in the comments. This would be the fourth election
of doing the same [__] that keeps netting us worse
and worse conditions and they haven't learned a thing. Truly,
medieval surfs have more independence of thought than this.
Exactly. It's it's mindboggling. It's so frustrating. These people
are our enemies. Okay. Until they
>> He's just looping. He's definitely looping. I just wanted
to see if he went to any more of the tweets.
>> Okay. But we're uh >> they DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
THEY don't >> I wanted I wanted to get Hassan's side. Okay.
I want to get Hassan's side before we go to the Hutch stuff.
And I don't know. Oh no. Actually, hold on. This is the sub >> any
candidate. This Gizm is sadly yet another him slamming the door
on them >> Uhoh. Uhoh. Hold on. We do need to do the Josiah
tweet first and then and then we can go. >> All of these
guys are destiny fans. As someone who rightly keeps his focus
on MAG, I'm going to briefly deviate and make a few observations.
this committee of the voting third party saying it doesn't even
matter as both indefensible and wrong. Um as may as well be seen
by Dems as him slamming the door on them thus motivating him
to go rightward. He could have said something like I can't say
because News needs to earn my vote if he wanted to apply leverage.
The very verse Democrat is objectively better than any MAGA candidate.
The schism is sadly yet another disadvantage we face in the anti-Maga
movement even as the stakes get higher and the terrain gets more
uneven.
I frankly heard had enough of the online blame game amongst the
anti-Trump coalition particularly blame the voters within these
blocks blaming one another for USA the millions of dollar as
a result blaming one another for the Palestinians. I don't believe
online political influencers have anyone else's interest at heart
except their own. Oh, he's not even reading the whole thing substance.
He's skipping lines. >> This is bull. Okay, this is if
that was the case, I would be moving very differently if I had
no investment in the things that I'm advocating for. I would
either decide not to work with any Democrat whatsoever and just
say I am the most moral leftist of all time. This is a bourgeoa
electoralist system. I will not be participating in it. Okay?
If I did not have any investment in advancing the causes that
I advocate for, I wouldn't do it. I wouldn't be in the trenches.
is I wouldn't be in the streets. I wouldn't be fundraising for
these initiatives. I wouldn't be working with the existing sitting
electeds right now to the best of my ability. I wouldn't be trying
to get people elected into positions of power if that was the
case. So, no, this kind of wishy-washy outsider where people
go, "Oh, like this guy simply only cares about himself is idiotic."
Okay, I've been saying the same exact [__] for the
past 12 goddamn years. I've been doing the same exact [__]
for the past 12 goddamn years and people still say, "He's grifting.
He's grifting. He's grifting." My positions haven't changed.
>> Yeah. Substance, you stupid [__] Ironically
enough, this is a rehashing of the 2016 era argument patient
over and over again by people who I thought had woken up to the
reality that Bernie would have been a far better alternative
to Donald Trump anyway. Infamous DG pondering politics.
I I'm probably just going to no comment that stuff unfortunately.
But yeah, I should just no comment that stuff. >> Charlie
Chong says, "Why are we doing 2028 loyalty pledges the news?"
>> I feel like the dismissal of that is a little bit >> February
226. Please be serious. >> You could do your own research.
This is a guy who refused to admit Israel's committing a genocide
has made California the most hostile place in the world to homeless
people and we're supposed to make zero demands and embrace them
in 2026. Such a brainwashed society where people are so convinced
we work for or owe politicians things like unconditional loyalty
when it's entirely backwards. Exactly.
Exactly. It's super simple. It's super simple that our our electeds
need to respond to us. Like at this point, I would say just on
the doxing alone, it's probably really bad optics for your YouTube
channel to be hanging around with that guy, right? Just on the
doxing alone. You to remove this scandal entirely. Just on the
doxing stuff alone. If you're hang out there, there's probably
something disturbed about you. Our electives need our electeds
need to listen to us. What's up, Vixie? How's it going? >> This
video you made is 8 years old in two days. ISIS Gestapa wasn't
popular then. Now it's the average voters's opinion. And people
still have the audacity to act.
>> No way. Is this like a Is this like a
There's no way he did like a film school
final project video on how Ice is Gestapo. No way. No way.
What about Aiden? We We don't associate very much with Aiden.
Um
yeah,
I also don't need to draw attention to it, but yeah, it's it's
a it's a thing with Aiden, too,
Okay.
as though this is from February >> I feel like this might
be really funny. If we go back and watch this, this might be
really funny. >> Eight years ago, and people still have
the audacity to make it seem like I I have positions that aren't
consistent. >> I will say in 2018, it would have seemed
absurd that ICE would beat up a white woman like this, a white
woman's all bruised up because of ice. No way. In
oh buddy, I that kind of be how it is, man. I don't know what
to tell you. in 2026. Yeah, white women be getting punched in
the face by people. >> As the contradictions worsen, people
start recognizing that the same old businesses usual establishment
democrat politics is not actually working, is not actually causing,
bro, I think you should re-release your old anyway. I don't believe
in online political influence if anyone else is interested. >> Oh,
I
I was not a fan of the dead domain
isn't about seeking truth and solutions specifically about grifting
and propagandizing while having their audiences fight each other
on their behalf. But I guess when the incentives are this misaligned,
it's all part of the game. Schisms and there's like a dead domain
tweet where she's like, uh, Gavin Newsome, the first thing Gavin
Newsome did after Trump got elected was say, we went too far
on trans people and that's why I hate him. I'm like, I get that.
But unfortunately, I think he said something that just is universally
accepted as true. I think it was like Dems went too far on trans
people in sports.
I think I think that's what he said. Like I can admit we were
wrong on that. It's like, well, unfortunately that's just like
a massively popular >> Drive engagement and payoff. Oh
god, everyone always >> tries to claim that there is some
cynical [__] Okay. Oh dude, there is must be a cynical
reason. Yeah, the cynical reason is the reason that I have openly
admitted over and over and over and over again. Throughout 2024,
you preach commonly get the only winning position. A weapons
embargo, which Paul showed would be the case and they ignored
you and lost because of it. Yes. What the [__] is
this? This is the link is not working. Care about what happens
to us, so stop acting like you speak. >> Okay, hold on.
I'm uh I need speeding through this cuz I want to get over to
the other stuff. one content creator. You [__] I
don't care about your fight with Destiny and all online idiots.
I'm just not supporting JD Vans. No, I NEVER SAID SUPPORT JD
VANCE. YOU BABOON.
>> YOU BABOON.
>> SHUT THE UP YOU DONKEY. There has never been there has
never been a moment where I have said I am in favor of voting
for JD Vans. >> I feel like those chatters know that they
make the content better by just saying things that are explicit.
>> You can always tell little confidence a Democrat. They're
like explicitly saying these things to upset Hassan and that's
why it's funny like that chatter knew he's like this is my moment
where I could say something totally ridicul I could say this
and I know for a fact this guy's going to lose >> hold
a potential candidate by early they freak out the left is not
voting for them. Yeah, better for that, too. But I'm not even
gonna get >> Okay. I don't know.
>> Further. We going any further? We done? We done? We
done? We done? We done? Are we done yet? >> [__]
up. >> Literally, what they're doing by refusing the reckless
podcast, by the way, Gavin. >> Oh, it's Gavin and Ben.
Gavin and Ben >> Let's fill up with >> Oh. Oh. Oh,
we got a Hutch moment. Hold >> The Liberals for Coalition.
>> Hold on, little I knew. I I knew I should have gotten
out too quickly. Wait, there was a Hutch and Why is there a Hutch
snark here? What? Here's how it's saying he would vote for Ben
Shapiro over you versus Hassan. Um, that's a little bit more
difficult, but
oh man, I mean like see the thing that you have to remember is
that with Assan
>> I I >> with Assan he's like anti-liberal democracy.
He like hates democracy. He actually like hates all people. He's
like a Marxist Leninist communist that will immediately kill
all of the capital owners the second any one of his candidates
is elected. Okay, >> So, you got to remember about Hassan.
>> I think Ben's foreign policy would be so
>> And at the same time, I think Hassan's foreign policy
would be like beyond bad. It It would be uh uh if you gave Assan
control of the most powerful military the world has ever known.
I don't like I I think like the implications why do we care about
what this guy is saying has no motion. He doesn't. The reason
why we're talking about this is because this is the type of [__]
that these guys are are talking about on that side of the bargain.
Okay. This is Hutch is just isolationist. Is he not?
Um
I don't know. I don't know what his foreign policy takes are.
The concern with Hassan is not him having the power of the the
world's most powerful military. The concern with Hassan is that
he would not take advantage of the world's most powerful military
to maintain like US hegemonic positions. Okay. I I think the
biggest concern you'd have with Hassan in terms of foreign policy
if you elected him if he was the commander-in-chief, let's say,
would be that he'd pull out of like the island chain strategy.
He would let China do whatever they want in the South China Sea
and China would just run buck wild on the entire Pacific
on that entire like Asian Pacific region.
Like that that's the concern you'd have.
Not that he would like go to war with somebody, it's that he
would pull them back from there. Yeah, that that would be like
he he instinctually just holds the wrong position automatically
at all times. I don't know why. He just like has the worst political
instincts I've ever seen on a human being. He just always gets
it wrong somehow. It's [__] crazy. >> The vote
blue no matter who. This is the the Hassan contingency of the
vote blue no matter who that says actually I'll vote red over
Hassan. You know
brother this Pestony literally said he'd vote for Adolf Hitler
before he would vote for me. Okay. In a hypothetical matchup
between me and Adolf Hitler. He said he would rather vote for
Adolf Hitler. Hutch would rather accept segregationist to the
party than parlay with leftists.
um who
were like
um who were I remember >> we had
cuz now he's like oh now we're going back in time no we're not
doing it through the ether [laughter]
through the ether he's being snarked the whole time okay >> he
could feel it he could feel it he's felt a shiver go up his spine
>> brand new prosegregationist coming into the Democratic
party would you welcome them because they have a D in front of
their name instead of R says no says no Hutch what about you
Maybe. Yeah, >> there you go. All right. Yeah. So, that's
a difference of opinion here, right? Like I'm against segregation
in this no matter what decade it is. >> Well, do you do
you I mean I don't want to get hung up too much. We can move
on to the next topic, but like do you think that Donald Trump
is a fascist?
>> Uh yes. >> Okay. And >> let me
like you'd have to accept as a like core tenant of this that
if this is going to be your only argument, you were just arguing
the party needs to move like way more rightward, right?
that you're conceding the Overton window like significantly and
maybe you say that's worth it in the short term to hold off from
some really negative
right? May maybe you say that, but you would have to acknowledge
that and I think a lot of these people are like the Overton window
is already too far rightward. We don't want to let it go anymore.
Do you think segregationist or fascist should be the counter
question? Do you think a Democrat that is a white supremacist
prosegrationist Democrat, do you think he's just as much of a
fascist as Donald Trump is? Because that's yes, the answer was
yes in that question.
Like what the [__] do you think fascism is? It's
not a totally separate thing than being a segregationist Democrat,
dumbass.
He had a lot to say about you this morning. I know. Hey, just
letting you know that you've tweeted about Hassan 22 times this
morning, but not once about the current DOJ oversight meeting
or ICE or anything besides Assan really. Again, it doesn't matter.
These guys only have one note, which is
I do I do wonder. Okay. The the general strategy if I were somebody
on this side
would be instead of pointing and laughing at how much power Fuentes
has and being like look these guys have to deal with Fentes.
Isn't that funny? Why don't you point out that like the reason
they have to deal with Fentes is just how like deeply embedded
he is and what that means about that party's future and direction.
And why aren't you focusing on that like a lot more than you're
focusing on Hassan,
right? Like there is a problem that the Gropers have seized a
ton of political power in the US. A ton, right?
And if you do just continue to seed the center over to the right,
you will eventually like
like those people aren't getting less power, right? Suddenly
they'll have a whole extremist flank to the right of them. And
I don't know, man. And communists are worse than Nazis. Well,
I just I don't understand the lack of focus there. I I don't
actually
>> they choose Ben Shapiro over me.
>> The reason you would say my stuff, but go ahead. >> Okay,
but tell me if I'm wrong, guys. The reason you would ever say
yes to a prosegation Democrat is because what's on the other
side is now the right has moved so far even past segregation
of Yeah, we're doing segregation and a lot more worse stuff.
Right now, I'm going to move on to the Pam Bonnie in a >> Oh,
right now.
That's what I thought. I'm going to do a little Hutch stuff.
Okay. So, that you not this, not this. Don't care about this
person. Where's my hutch? Where's my hutch stuff? Okay. Hutch.
Best day of Hutch's life today. Hutch woke up this morning, saw
that Hassan or maybe last night saw that Hassan had said, you
know, I don't care about who wins between JD Vance or I I don't
know. I'm not going to guarantee I vote either way on JD Vance
and Gavin Newsome. Best day of his entire life. Okay. He had
to go live this morning be like, I told you guys. I told you
all along. I told you. I told you. I told you. I told you. one
>> like the one the one with with the Sam Morton Joe actor
who who um is playing like the what is his name like the the
the toe hunter what what are they called? Uh, no. In the first
one, I don't know the name. In the second one, uh, Morton Joe
is his name. Yeah. >> Oh my god. You hold on. I'm also
>> I briefly like like a a groundhog. I briefly emerge
from my warren of taking on MAGA to criticize and
say, what did you say? >> Maybe if you would follow me
and take me off mute, maybe you would have seen it. >> I
do.
I love how I love how I said follow me and take off mute. He's
like, I do follow you. You didn't even my screen right now. No,
you are not >> you. Yeah, he's he's frantically >> Only
keep my focus on lefties. Is that what you're saying? >> I'm
saying for me it's the right decision. I think the primary focus
has to be on MAGA. I've made my peace with you being one of the
10 keeping the left in check. Um the rest of us, >> you
know. >> Exactly. I've made my peace with that. I think
I think that that has utility. >> Peter Zion said something
profound. Wow. Thank you. Only mute. Peter Zion said something
very profound. What is this? This is going to be
if this is totally off topic, you are super like not sitting
here for a while. >> Cluster of six, 7, 10, 15, 20, whatever
the number happens to be who agree to coordinate on not just
economic and financial issues, but political and security issues.
Cluster, not just >> this might be this might be interesting
for later. I might watch this video later. Maybe. Not right now,
though. >> I don't want everybody else to do it. I don't
think it needs to be 50/50. I think you have your purpose. You
do the lion share and the vast and overwhelming majority of us
need to be focused on >> I'm just talking about I'm just
talking about you said you're one in a million. You're one in
a million, buddy. >> All right. You said as someone who
rightly keeps his focus on Maga briefly deviate to make a few
observations. Committing to third party and saying it doesn't
even matter is both indefensible and wrong and may well be seen
by Dems as him slamming the door on them, thus motivating them
to go rightward. He could have said something like, "I can't
say because Newsome needs to earn my vote if he wanted to apply
leverage." The very worst Democrat is objectively better than
any MAGA candidate. This schism is sadly yet another disadvantage
we face in the anti-Maga movement even as the stakes get higher
and the terrain gets more uneven.
>> Yeah, that was the like nicest way you could have said
that. I think you even
>> Do you Do you think any of these guys watch the full
clip? I'm just I'm curious if there is anybody going to bring
up that there's like a second part to that clip and it cuts like
right as she's obviously saying something that would be interesting
to hear the response to.
Like I I feel like I'm the only person who followed this sphere
and like saw some of the principles and was like this would be
good to apply in the future. Everyone else was just like we're
going to win. I I'll do anything to win. And I'm like I think
some of the principles that we're all saying are important are
probably important actually. I think >> alternatives to
keeping the same position. I was like I'm going to hold out for
>> Hutch only started watching the full thing now on stream
after his combo with soy pill without saying >> well Hutch
isn't Hutch isn't going to change his mind no matter what. Hutch
is bought in. Hutch literally can't change his mind anymore.
Hutch has has worked himself into a position where changing his
mind on this would mean like basically deleting his channel.
Right there there will never be a chance to convince Hutch that
he's wrong on this. Hutch will always agree that that sorry he
will always believe that this is exactly what he needs to say.
Do you see this? No, I didn't see >> for a Democrat which
is like >> Yeah. I don't I don't have an issue with him
two years or anybody for that matter two years away from a hypothetical
scenario which may or may not unfold saying you know I'm not
going to precommit because you know that will just prompt this
person to take my support for granted because they know it's
fatal comply I'm not going to do that smartest I can't believe
you can so smartly say the the the best version of their position
and none of them can say this all of them are like I won't commit
I'm holding out for concessions but also after the election I
will admit that I never would have voted for them so it's >> oh
that there's no way that's real there's no way that could be
real. There's no way
that this could be real that they Okay, it's fine. We'll we'll
have this for >> Some of the some of the respon some of
the responses have been >> That is what Hassan said. And
I do think you only see it the way it is because of how it's
clipped, right? It's clipped disingenuously.
So, I do think that's
I I almost just replied to Josiah and asked just like, "Hey,
do you want to watch like the full thing and just see that like
after he basically implies that this far out from a primary,
he he won't commit to something like that." >> Wild. Wild.
Oh, there was one that really cracked me up. Somebody says they're
trying to clear the field for abundance Zionists. Two things
everybody but the donors hate and reject. That's what's up. We're
not stupid. And I'm like, you think Jennifer Welch is trying
to clear the field for abundance Zionists? Yeah, a lot of people
are like they're asking you to commit to Newsome before the primary.
It's like no, the question was if it was Newsome advance in the
general, not hey will you vote for Newsome knowing today what
you know. It's like no well if if if he's the elect. We don't
know. Like Jennifer even expressed reluctance there. She's like
you know I think she was I think she was quite far too generous
in my opinion um in her. >> She did not express reluctance
for
>> what I mean is like she she did the throat clearing
>> reluctance to agree with his opinion >> about
how much Gavin sucks and he's you know um you not ideal. Yeah.
Well, I think it went it went further beyond that. But then yes,
she said she would she say I dig through 10 ft of concrete or
something like that. >> Yeah. And she wasn't reluctant
to say that she would support him, but she was generous with
Hassan's criticisms of Newsome. Yeah. Newsome sucks and all these
all these things, but I would still support him. >> Anybody
who has not watched that entire exchange between Hassan and Jennifer
Welsh, it is the podcast episode that they posted yesterday on
I've had it that channel. So, if anybody in anybody's chat hasn't
watched that yet, I strongly suggest you do that because she
asks him, the shorter clip is just him or asking him, you know,
would you vote for >> Newsome and he says he would probably
vote third party. What the smaller clip doesn't show you is that
she then launched into what I thought was 95% a really articulate,
well thoughtout, logical reason to
>> I mean, it's an argument. She had an argument. I agree
with both sides of that argument, right? You don't have to say
either side of that argument are is wrong. I can see both sides
of that argument. The Hassan's point and her point, but Hutch
has acted like, oh, obviously she's correct because that's the
news. She spent >> using her lived experience as as a liberal
in from a red state, you know, talking about >> Yeah, she
Well, yeah, but she did that and then she I thought very correctly
tied it to vulnerable um people that live in red states, LGBTQ
plus people that live in red states. and she talked about it
for like 3 minutes and then >> that's what Josiah just
said, but I get that you wanted to speak and it's hard to listen
when you want to speak. So >> he responded that 5 minute
rant that she did and he opened it with, "Yeah, I don't even
consider any of that." And then like went into a rant about whatever
idiotic electoral strategy he is advocating for, which I just
thought was so telling, you know, like she spent three minutes
talking about how vulnerable people in red states are going to
be damaged if a Republican is elected and he leads with, "I don't
even consider that." Which I just thought was like so fitting
for him. It's like, "Yeah, we know. You don't actually give a
[__] about these people." Yeah. Hutch, do you feel
vindicated? All the people telling you, "Hutch Hutch voted for
Kla on stream. Hutch voted for Kla on stream." Like, yeah, he
didn't endorse her, but he told all his people. It was implicit
and he's just coming out right after. It's like the Trump thing
where like, you know, he's like, "Trump didn't say to drink bleach."
He he was actually exploring this potential, you know, thing
about, you know, maybe we can use UV light inside the body. And
then Trump comes out and just undermines all of them. He's like,
"Actually, I was being sarcastic, but I did say that." And it's
the same thing where it's like, yeah, like obviously he voted
for Connell on stream. He's just like, "No, I would I would vote
third party. I would never I would never vote for Dome." And
it's like, "Oh, okay." So, he didn't. Of
That's literally not what he said either. Um said probably third
party. Then he said I I just don't entertain that conversation,
you know, two years out, three years out.
>> I I didn't think he would come out and say that. I thought
he would I thought I thought he would do the same thing he did
last time, but he staked out of position way earlier this time,
which is just like such a clear attack vector. Be like, "We should."
>> Uh one of my chats said this, and this is obvious. I
just never have done this cuz I don't believe this. Have you
ever turned it around to be like, "If AOC is an omni, I refuse.
I I'll vote third party." Like, have you ever like turned it
on them like that? I've never >> See, as I told this why
I told you that they would try to flip that on you, right? Oh,
but we'd all vote for AOC if she won the primary.
Um, she never win the primary. Never ever winning the primary.
She'll literally never win the primary. Um, every time every
time a Dem
There's a chance, right? There's a chance for Dems to show what
would happen if a if a socialist type if a like lefty type won
a primary and it was with the Zoron thing and half of you
supported Cuomo. Okay. A bunch of supported Quomo as a third
party candidate. I I don't know how you expect the lefties to
trust you when that's what happens when the lefty wins the primary.
I don't that seems kind of up to be honest with you. >> Never
done this but >> no because I would never do that. I would
I would obviously don't, you know, >> the only thing I
could think of like what would their response be is just like
well that's already what the Democratic establishment does. That's
how they wrap for Bernie and like you know that that's kind of
the the narrative I would expect. But I I I prefer AOC to Newsome.
But if I didn't I would still, you know, drag my balls through
glass to go vote for her because Republicans, right? Like >> who
do you think would help more down ballot and who do you think
would be more effective in their legislative agenda, AOC or Newsome?
>> More effective. Oh, absolutely. Newsome. Like I prefer
AOC in terms of like policy-wise I align more with her but like
in the same way like I align more with Bernie but who who do
I think would have passed more legislation Bernie or Biden? Biden
like it would have been more Biden stuff but I think overall
executive experience either so like I mean to me to me Obama
really I mean he was senator very briefly he was very very fresh.
>> Oh did Hutch do something very similar? Oh boy
>> to destiny. Who would he vote for for president between
uh Hassan and Trump? He said Trump. He said he would vote for
the guy who supported Jan 6 over the guy who supported October
7. And I think
>> God that was so [__] dumb as a take. That
was the most take of all time. >> You disagree with that.
Okay. Thank you, Tony, for being here. >> All right. Thank
you. I appreciate it. >> I would Minecraft myself if you
force me to choose between >> Wait, do I know?
>> That's also very >> I think that's very Hold on.
And I think it's very important we all answer right now. Hano,
>> I would Minecraft myself if you forced me to choose
between those two. >> Okay. Okay. So, what about you, Wick?
>> See, but I think honestly
Oh, bro. I
[laughter]
That's That's That is rough, isn't it? That's That is rough,
is it not?
That is really rough. Is blue no matter who. Unless it was Hassan.
Could you imagine? Unless it was Hassan would be evil.
It's like, okay, all right. H I need to go back to watching Fentes
clips. I need some gropers back in here so I can uh I'm I'm getting
too many lefties in here. I'm seeing a bunch of people in chat
agreeing with all of this too much. I need to I need to find
some Fentes clips to watch or something. Okay, >> be very
careful. I'm I'm I'm >> way too many you guys in here right
now. Way too many. Way too many. Not that I want you guys to
leave. I'm just saying that I I need a balance. Okay. I can't
do an entirely lefty audience. It's It's untenable for me. Okay,
one second. What was the I just saw a link I wanted to click.
What is this? What is this? >> Like I don't think that's
disqualifying. >> No, I know. But I mean what I'm saying
is like for me um the point the part of the consideration there
is >> the argument would be that Hassan isn't blue. Wouldn't
that just be the argument for Zoron as well? Wouldn't that just
be the argument whenever you want to cut somebody out? Well,
actually they're not really a Democrat. they're like a leftist
and and like we don't trust them at all. Couldn't you just apply
that wherever you wanted? Isn't that line essentially arbitrary?
>> That one is actually an executive and the other one
isn't. So, it's easier to like stand on on Gavin's record. On
the other hand, you know, he he enjoys, you know, margins in
the California legislature that he probably wouldn't uh in the
United States situation. So, I don't know. It's an interesting
question. Whereas Biden and Bernie, I think that that was, you
know, that was a much cleaner um comparison to make. Um and Biden
was actually more legislatively successful than uh Obama, which
is actually it's funny. One of the things that
>> then then basically everybody's lying about this conversation
and it's like antagonistic anyway and nobody nobody should take
the other side seriously. >> Lowkey triggers me a little
bit and I understand why they do it cuz they're they're piss
off and there's some bad blood there. But like when the guys
upon Save America who I really like um you know they have a lot
of contempt and and talk Biden and part of me is like yeah but
he was on domestic issues. He was better than your guy ever was.
He got [__] done that Obama never could you know
so like ease up. You know what I mean? Um, >> I feel I
feel very conflicted about the strategy of throwing Biden under
the bus because on the one hand, like you, he was like literally
one of the most effective presidents of my lifetime, by far the
most progressive, by far the most pro- labor, by far the least
neoliberal, like he's the first president that broke from neoliberalism
since uh like before Reagan. And then on the other hand, it's
like you might have to sh on Biden to connect with the electorate
right now. Like Territo,
I don't like it, but I'm like, okay, that's probably going to
work. And I think we all agree that was the rock and hard place,
right? It's like, do I [__] on my current boss to
distance myself? And she chose not to. And I think that hurt,
but like that was a very hard decision. Okay. Well, it's similar
is what I'm saying is like the idea that like she could have
distanced herself from Biden, but like to what end the fact that
she was still his vice president at the time? >> That's
the part that makes it different. Like I totally agree. Like
obviously and there were people calling this at the time and
certainly hindsight has vindicated that view that it would have
been the right thing to do politically to distance herself from
the president or to throw him under the bus, but that's you just
you hit the nail on the
It's a retelling of history. Biden pressured her on Israel. Oh,
was she for was she more Zionist? I know. Biden was just like
this Netanyahu guy. He lied to >> She was the sitting after
president at the time. >> He told me he told me there were
100 beheaded babies and he had proof and then I said it and then
I look and old and that complicates things well beyond, you know,
like now candidates like Tel Rico didn't work for Biden. They
were just members of the same party, right? You know, and so
it' be it's a lot easier for people to throw a former president
under the bus than when you're the second in command of the the
administration at the time. Um, so I I don't envy that position,
but that's where Biden should have been >> responsible.
Um, her should >> throw me on the bus. Yes. He should he
should have said, "Do whatever it takes to beat Trump." That's
what he should have said, but he said >> he he pulled he
pulled a Ruth Waiter Ginsburg in some sense like the just hold
out. You can't take the keys away from grandpa sort of thing,
you know? >> Um, I actually have a question for real quick.
Uh, just because I I remember seeing this. Because I know I know
uh you're promi I remember people saying like oh Mani I think
this is true didn't endorse Kamala either in the same way Hassan
didn't. Do you have as much smoke for him or is it like >> oh
[__] >> you think his legislative successes
now are kind of like outweigh that or >> I'm not going
to dwell on the past. So, like if you're I feel like we got into
this Josiah, you and I, about um like Kyle and Crystal, and like
the reason why I'm still skeptical on them is because I just
need to see it. Like once we get past the midterms, if they really
are, you know, doing a kind of straight ticket Democrat sort
of policy, then I I would be willing to look past, you know,
criticisms that I might even think are unfair. Um but with Mumani,
you know, it matters to me less because number one, in his capacity
as a New York assembly member, that guy had less influence than
Hassan, like by orders of magnitude. Now, of course, it's different.
>> What if it Yeah. What if he did it now? like uh the
election was tomorrow and and how he's as big as he is. >> But
here's the thing though, I don't think he would because he is
demonstrating a genuine savvy in the political arena and so like
>> he's endorsing Hokll and he's working with these people
and it's like yeah I I
>> Yeah, Hutch Hutch doesn't dwell in the past guys. Hutch
never dwells in the
>> Why don't you why why do you have to go after Hassan?
Why can't you just ignore him? Well, actually when you see when
you look at his Drogram appearance six years ago, >> he
probably would not be the same person he was even a year ago.
That's probably >> He said that he hides his power level.
Okay. And that means we get to call him a liar all the time.
>> But you know, if somebody did stuff that I disagree
with in the past, but they're willing to get on the same page
now, I'm not going to go out of my way to pick fights with them.
And I think he's an asset to the Democratic party right now.
Number one, he does get young people excited and he gets them
to feel inspired and hopeful. And also number >> his popularity
is skyrocketing. I know that you had reservations about that
at first, but like and maybe things will change, but his his
popularity is just stratospheric or getting to that point. >> yeah,
I mean I don't know if he is as popular in New York. Maybe he
might be. Um, I think his numbers are like 5537
or something like that. Um, so I think he has a slight majority
approval, but the but the net like positive he it's like plus
15 or 20. And Hokll statewide is I think is around plus 15. So
they're both popular, but she has more power than him and she
doesn't have any serious primary challenger.
>> Yeah, but um they don't make any money off of criticizing
Jeff Bezos. Only people what you got to understand. >> And
he needs her support to deliver on her agenda. So, it's just
such an obvious no-brainer thing to endorse. But him doing that
got Hassan to say that he's not a betrayer of the regime. What
he said was he's Mani is not a betrayer yet. That's what he said
in in response to her doing and he called he called Mandani the
regime. And it's like how can you call these like I go out I
support these leftwing candidates that really understand what
I want to fight against the democratic establishment. But the
instant they even partly agree with a single person. They're
the regime now. Like mom donnie is the regime. AOC is the regime.
Bernie's the regime. It's like it's literally the contra points
meme. It's like you you literally just want critique power. That's
all you do. And it's frustrating because I see this person with
all this potential and money and and influence. And it's like
you're you just it's the thought terminating cliche thing that
you guys were talking about in my days. Like all right, now you're
part of the establishment. No more of that. I got you into the
establishment now. Now I don't support you. It's like like what's
the point? Like I I'm
I
would just want to ask soy here. I guess you think Hassan doesn't
support Zoro Mamani.
You think Hassan doesn't like Zoro Mamani or
I'm guessing that Hassan and Zoro Mamani had some talks about
the policy he'd be supporting and if he went against some of
those things sorry Hassan probably have criticism.
I I get the impression he still likes Zoram Donnie quite a bit.
>> I'm pretty sorry speaking of political
personal privilege there for just a second again because like
soon as my wife gets home I'm I'm going to dip out. Um, speaking
of Mani, because some of the people in my replies, um, were like,
you know, uh, what they call it, blue anon or blue MAGA or it's
funny how vote blue no matter who cuts both ways. I just wanted
on the record and and Hutch can vouch for this because we had
multiple high-profile disagreements. Hutch, can you vouch that
I was very much publicly blue no matter who when it came to Mani
and I was that prominent Democrats were not publicly endorsing
>> Can you vouch me there? >> 100%. Yeah. >> Yeah.
Thank you. I just I want that out there for you naysayers like
oh blue no matter who only applies to the more centrist candidate.
No, I'm I'm an equal opportunity offender and I said that the
centrist needed to Hakee Jeff and Chuck Schumer that they should
have been saying it much earlier blah blah blah. I just want
that out there. >> I mean I take blue no matter who. >> Hutches
Hutches on the record is no no no. Strategically they don't they
shouldn't do it. They don't have to do >> to I mean you
can try to test me with the craziest thought experiment you could
devise and I am not backing down. So people are taking a clip
from me on Live and Learn. Was it last week or the week before
where I said I would vote for the reincarnated uh corpse of Jeffrey
Epste if it meant delivering a Democratic party legislative agenda
and blocking Republicans from power? And I'm literally mean it.
I'm not joking. I'm I'm I'm not being sarcastic in the >> You
don't you don't even have to be that absurd to say I'd vote for
Bill Clinton over Donald Trump. Both of them are in the Epstein
files. Both of them probably did something weird with kids, but
like if it's part of the platform, right? That said, Hutch, didn't
you, if I remember correctly, you were not as reticent as Pisgo
and I were to condemn. I would just say probably
I would sincerely question any situation you find yourself in
where you have the like choice between two.
You know which one of these two am I going to make commander-in-chief
of the most powerful country on earth? Probably neither. I probably
What the [__] guys? Hey, why' we pick a I know they've
got a but why do we pick one? Wait, we have to pick a because
they have a
What the [__] Who made that rule?
Why would they make that rule?
couldn't we at least get is Epstein alive? Couldn't we just run
him directly? Couldn't we get a cool at >> Um the >> Just
kidding. Just kidding. Bill Clinton's obviously cool. >> Reason
all them for not endorsing Madani when he was the only Democrat,
right? >> Blue no matter who is a voting strategy. It's
not has nothing to do with political endorsements. So that's
the that's the difference. It's like blue no matter who is like
if you go to the ballot box and there's a Democrat on the ticket
you vote for that Democrat. The argument back then was is it
justified to be angry at >> who's the coolest probably
one of those Greek philosophers. Those guys were allian right
>> at national politicians that serve at the federal level
in the in the US Congress for not endorsing a mayor like a may
like a mayor's race in a city like [clears throat] New York City
that's plus 32 Democrat in 2024. Um, that's like a totally different
debate um than, you know, should I vote for the Democrat if they're
on my ticket? >> Gotcha. Okay, fair enough. >> Hey,
sorry to interject with one other thing here, but just I'm scrolling
while I'm looking at this and uh uh somebody a photographer just
caught Pam Bondi in that hearing. She was given a >> Oh,
is this real >> copy of >> Oh, hold on. And that's
what somebody sent me was a picture of like apparently Pam Bondi
had written down what Jaipal Primala had searched out of the
Epstein files
which how the did she get this? I didn't think this is real.
It's like an art our conspiracy post. Okay. But now Josiah's
bring it up. That leads me to believe that this is actually just
real and it was like shown on the TV.
That's incredibly right. That's got to be incredibly dude. This
is nuts, man. >> Primila Gyipol's search history for the
Epstein files. Like what Primila Gyipol was searching in her
review of the Epstein files that was part of Pam Bondi's burn
book to go after like going viral. Like Primilla literally Primilla
Gipol search history right in the binder. The [__]
Pilipol [clears throat] was looking at. That's >> Wait,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa. Hold on. Show me a clip of
this. Are you saying she just >> Here, I'll send it to
you. Now it says search history. It's I don't know if it's search
history. It's like I'm guessing this is slightly less bad than
I'm guessing Congress people know if they search stuff on their
devices that's open to scrutiny by like US investigators somehow.
I'm guessing you basically don't get privacy as a Congress person
from US investigators. But it still feels insanely improper for
this to be done, right? I'm guessing there's probably a decent
chance that laws weren't broken here.
New Brazilian just arrived. Something cute. Oh, these are the
these are the Epstein files she looked at. Just to be clear,
these aren't her this isn't her search history. These are like
the numbers for the Epstein files and the thing that was said
in the Epstein file email.
This isn't her searching the stuff just for fun.
This is uh this is the Epste file stuff, okay? Uh not her like
looking for little kids or some [__] >> Are
they did they literally like
>> bro? Check this out. It's It's all over Twitter now.
Or did you send it? >> Did you post it in the uh the chat?
>> I sent it to you DM. I just DM'd it to >> Sent
to soy, too. >> There's no way. Hold on. >> What
the
>> enance
in the files?
No, it's illegal. >> This is really bad. >> Still
possible. Where >> are we? >> It's not enough to
just win the election and play it inch by inch or syllable by
syllable. Like we have to make some major institutional reforms
um I think in this country to for Democrats to be competitive
or more or as competitive as they should be. And um really really
tough. So
>> why is Bondie doing that? I
Well, I here's the thing is I don't I think it's beyond like
um keeping audit logs or whatever Canadian caller. I'm guessing
it's something like literally if you're searching stuff on your
congressional devices on on stuff that you you have as a part
of your job as a congressperson. I'm guessing that's all open
to investigation at a whim by law enforcement by like federal
law enforcement or something. Like I'm guessing there's some
rule where that's not super illegal, but it's still insane to
use it for like to do counter propaganda or something at a congressional
hearing. That's it's nuts. Sorry to throw a lot at you, but that's
I mean like so there's there's validity to that. I I obviously
think that you should always be forward thinking and and and
think about the potential obstacles ahead. >> By the way,
just to be clear as well, I I'll throw another thing out there.
I'm pretty sure the Green Lantern theory, all of this, the abundance
Green Lantern theory, we should allow segregationists. Does that
not explicitly like also say you should allow leftists and like
literally if they can help the the coalition, like if they're
easier to get voted in somewhere? Doesn't that isn't that what
that means?
Why would it be everybody but leftists? Why would it be? Yeah.
Like Nazis, you know, pro-life people, um, segregationists,
you know, basically anything like leftists. No, no, no, no, no,
no. Those people. [__] They're not part of They're
not a part of this coalition. I can I can abide racism. I can
abide. I can abide natalism that, you know, verges on taking
away I still I tried to I tried to go a different way, but I
cannot abide communism. Okay. I can I can abide anything else.
I think there's a difference between considering the possibility
of these things manifesting in the way that you're describing
and kind of like living in that fear and anxiety. And I think
one thing that allows Trump and his movement to flourish is when
people feel beaten, apathetic, and hopeless. And so I think it
is the [__] is the Green Lantern theory? Don't worry
about it.
Hold on. Asold said he was fine with executions for this kind
of Okay, we'll have to hold this for the Epstein stuff as well.
Okay, we'll have to hold this. Asold calling for more political
politically advantageous to consciously choose to allow some
optimism into your thinking. And I can't help but feel >> I
feel like I'm starting to not care about this stuff as much and
I'm about to say let's go on to the Epstein Files. Okay, this
has been fun. I enjoyed doing this. It's a good way to knock
off, you know, a couple hours on stream. Have some fun doing
it. But the Epstein files await. I think it is time to head over
and and do those. Okay,
so let's take a quick look. I've got a link. Wait, I've got actually
timestamps for this. Give me a second.
Ooh,
hold on. I'm also hearing that very possibly
Hassan [__] might also watch the Nikandros video.
Okay, good chance that Hassan [__] may also watch
the Nicandra video.
We We're get We're Are we going to get everybody to watch? Is
it Is it going to blow up everywhere? Is everyone Everyone everyone's
going to watch it. Oh my god.
Hold on. What did somebody say?
Check Asmin. What is this? What did you link? Check Asmin.
>> This is a lot of people.
>> Oh, Asmin Gold had to take.
What does Asmin Gold say here?
Asmin Gold is going to
totally take the side opposite Hassan. One, for spiteful reasons,
but that's maybe not even the most important part over the Emmy
stuff. And two, for like political division reasons, leftists
and democrats being friends is totally against what what Asmagold
is looking for, right? He does not want anything. He doesn't
want these people working together. He wants them working against
each other. I
it's very obvious that he why he would want that, right? He is
looking to help his movement. Are very very angry today about
this clip. Oh my god. When asked he vote for Gavin Newsome or
JD Vance for president, Hassan said that he would vote third
party. This proves Hassan doesn't care about any marginalized
groups he pretends to support. All he cares about is taking money
from them so we can buy more outfits for his stream. Why do you
give this? What is this? Like this is a tiny little water bottle.
>> Okay, let's watch it
for him. Disappointed in >> for JD Vance or Gavin Newsome.
Well, I'd have to vote for Gavin Newsome. Of >> I wouldn't
blink. What about you, >> I'd probably >> Does he
defend him?
I'm going to have to think about why he does that if he does
defend him. We'll see. We'll see how it >> He would >> Oh,
yeah. I mean, I at that point it doesn't even matter like cuz
my policy on this is is the same as like my refusal to endorse
Kla Harris. Um, the reason why I did not endorse Kla Harris.
>> Oh, well, there is the fact that Asminold is currently
advocating against voting for Republicans everywhere.
Wait, I I forgot that Asmin Gold has been openly saying, "We
shouldn't vote Republicans. They're not actually doing anything
we want. These people don't represent us." I forgot he's been
on the exact same page as this. Like, hey, these people don't
represent us. I forgot. So, he's going to have to defend that
cuz that is his political position. >> Was because she
did things that were not only unproductive, but also
>> I I got to say it. I think Assan's right. I do. I don't
think that you have I don't think that you should have the moral
authority to tell someone that they're obligated to choose the
lesser of two evils if they feel uncomfortable doing so. And
I think that he has every right to make a conscious object basically
be a conscientious objector to an election and choose not to
vote for those lesser of two evils. I think the people that are
angry at him are being >> Um but >> can I just ask
like why is it when the other guy is evil you pick your most
evil guy? Like you got Trump the first time and it's like who
does everybody think like eats kids and is evil in general? Hillary
Clinton. Runner. Runner right now. Run her right now. Run her
right now. Run her immediately. Break that glass ceiling. Let's
go. It's like, could you just pick someone people like? Maybe.
Could you just like pick someone a little more popular? Maybe
you have to see Trump and be like, we could run anyone against
this. We can we can put a real monster in there.
But by the way, I I do think I still think you should have voted
for Hillary. In retrospect, Hillary Clinton was like the the
final that's the filter for humanity as a civilization. The fact
that people couldn't get behind Hillary Clinton and decided to
vote for Trump instead, that's like showing that we'll never
ever harness the energy of the sun. We'll never leave the galaxy.
We will never be a space fairing race in any meaningful way.
We we missed that filter opportunity. Okay, we we got filtered.
We won't be a great civilization in the universe ever. That that
was the the moment right there was could we could we put how
much we didn't like women and how much we didn't like like
you know this evil person who we' heard rumors about. Could we
identify what information was real at the time? Nope. Nope. We
couldn't. We actually lose. We actually lose. >> And I
still stand on that. I still talk about it all the time because
people constantly bring it up like you didn't sufficiently like
promote Kla Harris. >> But like there's also like this
is the other truth, right? The two people Renee Good and Alex
Prey would probably still be alive right now if Kla Harris was
the president.
This is undeniable. And I think that you should acknowledge that
whenever you say if I'm if you're going to be making a principled
voting decision, you there will be consequences for that. And
in not choosing the lesser of two evils, sometimes you end up
getting the greater of those two evils. Like some and again,
am I wrong about this? You need long-term thinking. You do, but
like even if you like having long-term thinking doesn't remove
your accountability. Like both things are true. You should say,
"Yes, they died. That's bad or whatever, but this is still where
my principles are." I think that trying to, you know, uh assume
that nothing else bad happened is unfair. You can't uh you can't
put those deaths because of that. Okay, I'm I'm going to pull
you up. How many people would be dead because of illegal migrants?
I understand that.
Do you think that they would still be alive right now if Kla
Harris?
[laughter]
You don't know that. You can't say that. Maybe they'd still be
dead. Maybe maybe Trump didn't get them. >> Who's the president?
>> Asmin Gold picks the smartest shatters to fight. >> I'm
sorry. I don't care about this >> things that they support.
Now you I can't I can't push for this. >> Promote Kla Harris.
You're the reason why she lost that that's happened. >> But
I just don't think that's the reason why you should pressure
him into doing it. Every decision has consequences. To pretend
like it doesn't is a lie. >> Efficiently like promote Kla
Harris. You're the reason why she lost. I'm like I am incapable.
There is no singular force in this country that is capable of
making or breaking an election. And if that was real, then it
is the most idiotic thing not to listen to my demands. But everybody
knows that that's not real, right? If I had this singular force
to be able to make Kla Harris as the president, then Kla Harris
should be coming to me every day. It's undeniable that people
that are trying to push for a third party like yeah obviously
they do hold a sway in the election depending on what happens
for sure >> and being like let me do a collab with you
please right that's not the case of course and they know it that's
why they didn't do it but >> um the the campaigns are always
responsible for whether or not they're able to win uh the crowds
win the population over and and you know combat against the couch
not necessarily even against the Republican party but usually
you're fighting against the couch people who just don't go out
and vote. Yeah, he's right. >> And for me, the way I see
it is if the Democratic establishment makes this decision one
more time, just as they did with Hillary Clinton, just as they
did with Kala Harris, and in some ways, just as they did with
Joe Biden as well, >> I think that's one of the reasons
why Hillary Clinton didn't win, it's because they obviously like
they roached out on Bernie. I think that if they have if they
had given Bernie an honest shot and the voters for Bernie felt
like he was treated properly, I bet Hillary Clinton might have
won the election. And the reason why is because at least they
wouldn't have been disrespected and lied to and manipulated.
that whenever you take and you sideline your most passionate
group of people who care the most about your ideals. Bernie was
a liar. Okay. Well, if she's a liar, then what does that make
Clinton? Uh yeah. So, if you sideline those people, you demotivate
them to go out and vote for you. You do. Oh, how do I put this?
I do think there was some bad stuff with Bernie, obviously.
Obviously, I do. I actually think the second time around was
worse than the first time around. I think he was I think he was
losing the first time.
If he'd run like he was Trump, if Bernie had run with an attitude
like he was Trump, like I'll burn this whole thing down if I
don't win. Everybody here, you all suck. If he just constantly
been like, "You're a corrupt [__] You're a corrupt."
If he if he'd done the Trump thing, he could have won, I think,
in that first primary, but he was always losing that first one.
The second one, it was like weird how he got with. Okay.
No, no, no. He wasn't he just wasn't like he he wasn't narcissistic
enough to be president. That's facts about Bernie Sanders. He
was not narcissistic enough to be president. You need to actually
love the smell of your own farts to be president. It's like just
obviously true. Okay. You ever hear Obama speak? You ever hear
Obama
Okay, wait, better question. You ever see Obama like walk somewhere
with like headphones in? I guarantee you Obama got a speech from
Obama loaded up on those headphones. Okay. Obama loved hearing
himself talk.
Yeah, Obama love hearing himself talk. Okay. You need to love
yourself on a level that is not common amongst humanity to become
president. And Bernie doesn't have that. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I think the super delegates didn't as bad as people think. I
think that's my opinion. >> Uh speaking of as they just
watched this insane clip on Twitter. I think that's going to
be parties have trouble. >> Oh, maybe not. That might be
what the time stamp was, >> but we'll wrap up the previous
segment. >> I know that. But like inside of swing states
and certain different districts, they do make a difference and
an impact. And you can see that with the votes for Jill Stein
in 2024, for example. It's
which led to Trump too, then they just don't care. And there's
not >> Let me tell you something. I agree with everything
you say, but as a person who lived in a red state for 50 years,
I would crawl through 10 feet of concrete to vote for >> Obama
[laughter] wrote about how he learned Marxist theory for the
sole purpose of getting that man was built different. Jesus Christ,
even though I think he's duplicitous, a hypocrite, a thirst trap,
hungry for power, all of the things that you say and harms the
Democratic party and sets the psychological soil to be more prey
to fascism. All of that I agree with. But there are so many young
queer, black, brown, marginalized people in red states. And even
though this corporate Democrat is, you see it in a long-term
game, in the short-term game, a President Nsome over President
JD Van. >> Yep. There it is. It's emotional. I mean, again,
like I just
Here's here's my opinion. I think these are two philosophical
decisions and neither of them are wrong.
That That's >> Oh god. Oh god. No.
Asold, no. Please don't say my opinion. Asold. Asold, stop. Stop.
Don't do it. Don't do it to me. Don't do it to me. >> My
view point is >> I don't think either one of them are wrong.
And anybody who's trying to assert that their viewpoint is like
it's un you can't criticize it. You can't talk about it. You
can't fight against it. I think they're full of I think the fact
is that it's totally valid what she's saying. It's totally valid
what Hassan is saying. You should never expect somebody to vote
for the lesser of two evils. You should never think that you
have the moral authority to say you should vote for something
and you have to vote for something and you're morally obligated
to vote for my candidate because I mean I think moral I don't
know I don't really care about saying moral obligation. It's
just like it's smarter to vote for the person who's the lesser
of two evils for you. Um in in the short term obviously
I I think moralizing it making it moral is weird or him even
arguing about the morality of it is weird. I just think it's
like probably bad to vote for JD Vance in the 2024 or 2028 election
if that's the case. All right. I do think it's quite bad.
Embarrassing day for the centrist lives when Asmin looks like
the reasonable one in comparison. Yeah, I mean he he is just
right. It's pretty obvious I I think as an outsider looking in
that this is how you gain power. This is how you like try to
force your party to change in the ways you want it to change.
It's just obviously true because it even though it doesn't fulfill
your principles, it's closer to what I think your principles
are than this other person. So, you're now obligated to take
my side. It's unfair. It's completely unfair. Oh, he he he replied.
You're in a you're in a led by a streamer. What What the does
that even mean?
Destiny. What the does this have to do with Destiny? I mean,
it it unironically does in this case, but this is why I think
it's better for Hassan to not lean into this, right? I think
Huzzan leans into this and I get it
but um
but I do think it's better not to lean into it is
you you give this person power. It's the same thing that happens
with Assan. People give Assan so much power and he gains power
from that. Right? When you treat someone like they have a bunch
of power, they gain power from it.
Not strategically intelligent. Okay.
>> But I'm disappointed. I >> I hang on. I just holy
OP is a destiny fan after all this Republicans don't anything
Democrat does ever again future mega prison camp guard I mean
I don't know this is just some liberal right I mean who cares
uh I think Hassan can defend like calling this guy whatever he
wants in regards to Destiny just based on the history he pulled
up I think that's not
>> the day he goes Republican you will too oh the day Destiny
goes Republican you didn't care when he boosted Sam Hyde Nick
Fuentes or Warren Southern Destiny yeah don't talk to about obeying
in advance. Vote vote blue no matter who got us in this mess.
Jesus,
man. I uh wow, they're cannibalizing each other. Well, really,
I mean, I think this is the problem is that I think leftists
know or like liberals know that the hardline leftists like Hassan
have consolidated enough influence and power that if they try
to work against a liberal establishment candidate, they will
probably contribute to that candidate not winning the election.
I think this is generally true, actually, and they've grown to
be very influential and there's a lot of them that are out there.
Now, I'm not saying that it's a huge amount, but even if it's
5%, 5% can swing an election. So, you can say, "Oh, wow. It's
not that many numerically or like comparatively, but you know,
for how many there are, it can cause the difference in between,
you know, a 5150 toss up, right?" So, what I think is happening
is that they're angry. Why did he just call it a 5150? What the
[__] is wrong with this guy?
A 50
that they can't ideologically browbe these. We got a wellness
check on Emiru right now or can we get a wellness check on Emiru
immediately? I think the I think I think the Aryan Emmy memes
have been getting to her. >> Remaining 5% of people into
voting the party line and that's fundamentally what it is. They
want to browbeat, virtue signal and demonize anybody who refuses
to vote the party line. And the fact is that a lot of people
are actually in agreeance against this. Like they bro
strategy you guys never learn. Uh it's even if you intend to
vote for Biden, you should not say it and use the leverage in
order to push for more concessions. I mean again I think that
can possibly be true. I didn't know that. Tell me it's the first
time. What is this? >> It's definitely the second best.
So, if Joe Biden got the got the nomination and is running against
President Trump, you would not vote for him. >> I don't
know. >> Uh, if Asen Gold says, "Wait, Hassan voted for
Joe Biden, though, so obviously this proves his point." I'm going
to be so mad. >> I'm honestly considered moving up into
the mountains of his lifestyle. >> Don't take my points.
Don't take my >> Yeah. I mean, obviously,
hypothetical vote misunderstands how political engagement works.
What is this here? The premise here is political morality is
measured exclusively at the voting booth. Well, I mean, it is.
I mean, you either make the decision or you don't. It's not that
complicated. If you don't vote for the performative lib who started
last year agreeing with Charlie Kirk about trans women, then
you hate marginalized groups. I mean, if you choose the greater
if you don't choose the lesser of two evils and then the greater
of two evils prevails, you do have a responsibility to that because
you made a choice. Not choosing is a choice. You decide. Now,
you can say that you're not going to do that, but don't go and
say that you're perfect for it, right? This is what's so insane
to me. Why are people What is this all about? Yeah, it's a trolley
problem. So, just make the decision. If you think that it's better
long-term to have more people suffer because then that will push
your ideology, then just say that. And the >> But I think
I do literally think that's what Hassan said. No. Is that not
literally what Hassan said? Like, yeah, in the short term it
has like these negative consequences and that sucks, but I think
in the long term, if we continue to do this thing where we ratchet
to the right, we'll eventually end up at some form of fascism.
That's like his thoughts on it. It sounds like he's aware of
the downsides. Now, if you want to say, well, you aren't in one
of those groups that will face the downsides, like you're disproportionately
disfavoring people who will see the downsides, right? You don't
live in a red state. You're not a part of these marginalized
groups. That's also fair. You'd have to agree. The problem with
a lot of these leftist people are is that they do not say what
they actually believe. The fact is that they want things this
is the ideology that they have. They want things to get worse
so that way people are radicalized enough for vote to to vote
for a candidate that they agree with.
Uh I don't think that's true. And I I do think asminold sympathizes
with that viewpoint which is why he sees it. I don't think that
part's true that they want it to get worse.
Um I I think Asminold literally wants it to get worse. He is
an avowed accelerationist,
but I don't think that's necessarily what they want. I think
they're looking at it like they don't want the thing that's coming
and they they feel like the only way to slow it down is this
this approach. I I think that's subtly different than Asmin Gold.
I think they probably, you know, Hassan probably believes the
accelerationist approach is something like just voting for whatever
candidate they give you. That's probably what he would argue.
I I guess >> that's what their goal is. just say that there's
and it's not insane to say, but it's really not. I think it's
reasonable. You're American, so vote, but you're you are responsible.
Yeah, they always invoke the marginalized people argument, but
they never say what the [__] that means or in what
way they're impacted. How are they impacted? Well, I'll give
you some examples, right? So, Donald Trump has gone on a number
of things that have damaged trans people's ability to do certain
things. Like, I think the best example that I can use is in the
military. He kicked all the trans people out of the military.
That's obviously something that if you're trans, you're probably
going to be against even if you think that, you know, they shouldn't
be in the military. This was very clearly something that trans
people were able to do that Donald Trump took away. He took it
away. So I think that it's undeniable that's the case. Same thing
with trans and sports. Now I know it's a 9010 issue, but there
are the 10. And so whenever that 10% sees that, that is a reduction
in the amount of things that trans people can do. Did they really
kick them out or stop paying for it? Uh they kicked them out.
Yeah. They they literally kicked them out. Like they said they're
they're getting rid of
>> These are the same thing. By the way, saying you're
like not not like taking something away from people because you
stop funding it is in office. gets revolutionary which raises
his profile and makes him more money. That's what he cares about.
I mean I I country it's doesn't matter then they should be in
right it's right I mean that's not necessarily not vote for Gavin
you really know the thing to not preemptively swear you vote
for Gavin Newsome before he's valid if you don't any work during
that time yeah well if that's the case for too many of them you
shouldn't have doesn't make you team he is indifferent vote for
Gavin News push somebody else's values on sorry your values on
somebody else >> vote for JD Vance or Gavin Newsome >> have
to vote for Gavin >> I wouldn't blame what about you >> I'd
probably vote third party >> you would >> he's gonna
get mad I just uh [__] him dude [__]
HIM BRO HUTCH STARTS GOING MAINSTREAM WHAT LET'S GO. Hutch Stark
is out. We out
>> We're the Listen, this is the channel you come to when
you want to know what your favorite influencer will be watching
6 months from now. Okay? Driving the discourse, driving the direction.
We know what we know where the ball is moving. Okay? We're always
looking where the ball's moving
or in this case, the uh bald head is moving. Okay? opposition.
Political opposition not on the team, guys. He is not on the
team. He is indifferent to Republicans having power and all of
the people that are harmed by that happening. He is opposition.
Okay. >> In no uncertain terms. This is nuts. This is a
bananas thing to say a year into this administration.
>> Who dead people in Minnesota? Minnesota. Wow. How many
>> It's called snowadishu. >> How many people did
we send to like
>> Okay. I've not heard snowadishu before given the Somali
and everything. That is funny. Okay, I'm going to I I'm going
to say it. Snogadishu is hilarious. >> Torture prison in
ccot. Did we >> not enough? Should have been more. Should
have been a lot more. >> Didn't we send possibly like American
citizens there on accident? >> Um can't win them all. >> The
the mass deportation program, ICE terrorizing [laughter] civilians,
millions dead, US ID cuts, 11. I've got to break a few eggs to
make it all my guys. A couple American citizens get deported
to a place where people like die and get tortured. Ah, what can
you do? Got to break a few eggs to make an >> Huge W. >> Weak
blockade of aid going into Gaza, which almost which very nearly
caused a mass starvation event. >> I have no idea. >> Very
close to being officially designated a famine. >> Uhhuh.
Surely Hamas had nothing to do with that. >> Dismantling
the Department of Education. >> Thank God. >> thank
God. Kids are rich nowadays. Obviously, it doesn't work. >> Blowing
up fishermanmen in Venezuela. >> rip bozo. Shouldn't have
been selling drugs. Shouldn't have been running drugs around.
There's a fishing submarine. Now it's dead. Too bad. Shouldn't
have done it. uh you know invading Venezuela, >> Got him.
You got nab. Now you're in a box. We win. Now we got your oil.
W >> leader. I guess we're doing change again. Just very
blatantly and openly at this point. >> Of course we are.
We We spent a trillion. We spent trillion dollars on the military.
Nothing. SP spending all this money on the military just to not
do anything. We spent a trillion dollars. We can't even go get
this piece of [__] What do you mean by that?
I haven't even I haven't There's like Why does he do the accent?
It's like he does different accents for different shorts. He's
like doing the America. He's doing the America [__]
abbit and he like gets this yokal accent going.
Yeah. W
What the you mean, man? What the you mean, >> [__]
dozen. >> The code switching is crazy >> of other
just
>> uh Did you see that? Knox ended his stream early because
he had a migraine. I did not. Do you think that migraine has
something to do with Msk watching the video andor I'm hearing
through the grapevine necandros?
Seems quite possible that we might have a Hassan the Hun viewing
of the video as well.
Is that Am I hearing that? Am I hearing? We may have a Hassanabi
viewing of the Nicandra video coming up. Hassan [__]
is also viewing it. He said it on stream. Let's go.
Let's go.
Literally. Yes. Well, that's fantastic, Nandros, isn't it? it.
By the way, the great part about that Nantro is not just that
the haters are boosting it because this isn't a video that is
like um you know just playing to haters. This is a shot video
that is very justifiably
trying to end Nux's career. This is a harmful is a somebody who
should not have a platform. Get him the out of here. Okay, I'm
happy the haters will boost it, but I think this will go way
beyond the haters. You know what I'm saying? This will go to
everybody. Everybody will want to watch this. really awful damaging
things that he's done as president and like >> sounds like
a list of W's to me >> like no I don't know if I can I
would vote third party you bro this guy man there's a lot of
people out there here's the truth too is that they can always
virtue signal about how it's not a big deal it's not a bad thing
to vote third party or sorry it is it's a good thing to do that
but they never have to live with the consequences of it that's
another big point like Hutch is right to an extent right is that
like yeah a lot of things again like if you're a liberal like
you're probably very upset about it but none of these people
have to do that at all
damn
All right. All right.